we are examining what Mr Johnson said to
the house about gatherings in number 10.
whether what he said to the house was
correct or not whether and if so how
quickly and comprehensively any
misleading statement was corrected
if a statement was misleading we will
then consider whether that was a genuine
error or if it was Reckless or
intentional and whether the record was
corrected in good time
we have already considered evidence
supplied by the government including
emails WhatsApp messages and photos
taken at the time and written statements
taken under oath from Witnesses present
at the relevant times to inform us of
what Mr Johnson would have known at the
time of his statements to the house
there has been much comment about
whether the committee is relying on the
Sue gray report material
we are not relying on any such material
and nor will we
last November we decided to collect
direct first-hand evidence from all the
witnesses under oath and this has all
been disclosed to Mr Johnson
Sue gray is not a witness
we have followed the standing orders of
the house and the Precedence as advised
by our clerks by speakers Council and by
Sir Ernest Ryder a former law justice of
appeal
we have not changed the rules or the
procedure
that is not within our remit they are
laid down by the house we are bound to
follow them and that is what we've done
in our report of the 3rd of March we set
out the main issues which we will be
asking Mr Johnson about today
we'll be talking about rules and
guidance since Mr Johnson told the house
number 10 complied with both
when we refer to rules we mean
regulations laid down by the house which
have the force of Law and under which
fixed penalty notices were issued
guidance is guidance issued by the
government for example
when Mr Johnson was talking about hands
face space he was referring to the
guidance on social distancing when he
said space
on the basis of information that is in
the public domain and evidence the
committee has received and in the
context of what Mr Johnson said to the
House of Commons we will be establishing
what rules and guidance relating to
covids were in Force at the relevant
time
Mr Johnson's knowledge of those rules
and guidance
Mr Johnson's attendance act or knowledge
of gatherings that were not socially
distanced and those for which to fixed
penalty notices were issued
Mr Johnson spoke about the question of
covet compliance in number 10 in the
House of Commons more than 30 times most
particularly on the 1st of December 2021
the 8th of December 2021 and the 25th of
May 2022
I'd like us all to have a reminder now
of some of what Mr Johnson said in
Parliament in answer to questions
starting if we may with a question from
the leader of the opposition on the 1st
of December
as millions of people were locked down
last year it was a Christmas party
thrown in Downing Street for dozens of
people on December the 18th
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
what I can tell the right honorable
gentleman is that is that all guidance
was followed completely during number 10
but I
repeat Mr Speaker that I have been
repeatedly assured since these
allegations emerged that there was no
party and that and that no covid rules
were broken and that is what I have been
repeatedly assured
I apologize I apologize for uh for the
impression that has been given uh that
staff in Downey Street take this less
than seriously uh I'm I I'm second
myself and Furious about that
said to him that that
I've been repeatedly assured that the
rules
the Prime Minister has been caught
red-handed why doesn't he end the
investigation right now by just
admitting it
because Mr Speaker I've been repeatedly
assured that no rules of Republican
the Prime Minister tell the house
whether there was a party in Downing
Street on the 13th of November
but I'm sure that and whatever happened
uh the guidance was followed and the
rules were followed at all times
and
I'm happy to set on the record now
that when I said I came to this house
and said in all sincerity that the rules
and guidance would be followed at all
times it was what I believed to be true
certainly the case when I was present at
house will note that my attendance at
these moments brief as it was has not
been found to be outside the rules
but clearly this was not the case for
some of those Gatherings after I have
left and at other Gatherings when I was
not even in the building
thank you
we need to understand
Johnson said to Parliament that no rules
or guidance were broken in number 10
when we have evidence that he knew what
the rules and guidance were
and that he was present at Gatherings
where those rules and guidance were
breached
we have yet to reach our conclusions in
this inquiry and we will not do so
until we have heard and considered Mr
Johnson's evidence today
the evidence that we have already raises
clear questions
and this is Mr Johnson's opportunity to
give us his answers
will the clerk to the committee please
administer the oath
the Bible
and read out the terms of the oath yes I
swear by almighty God that the evidence
I shall give for this committee shall be
the truthful truth and nothing but the
truth so help me God
thank you very much
Mr Johnson you provided the committee
with a written submission which the
committee has published do you confirm
that the contents of that statement are
true I do
thank you Mr Johnson please make your
opening statement thank you uh chair if
I can before I begin I'm conscious that
we're all expected to vote in a few
minutes I think at 221
um I hope you don't mind if I
resume I mean it will break up but what
I'm about to say well we're a
parliamentary committee and Parliament
is continuing if there is a vote called
which we do expect I will suspend the
sitting to enable members to vote and we
can pick up from where you left off but
thanks for reminding everybody thank you
thank you thank you thank you chair well
as you've just said there were a number
of uh days over a period of 20 months
when Gatherings took place in Downing
Street that went past the point where
they could be said to be necessary for
work purposes that was wrong I bitterly
regret it I understand public anger and
I continue to apologize for what
happened on my watch and I take full
responsibility but as you've just said
chair the purpose of this inquiry is not
to reopen so-called party gate it is to
discover whether or not I lied to
Parliament wittingly misled colleagues
and the country about what I knew and
believed about those Gatherings when I
said that the rules and the guidance had
been followed at number 10.
I'm here to
say to you hand on heart that I did not
lie to the house when those statements
were made they were made in good faith
and on the basis of what I honestly knew
and believed at the time
when this inquiry was set up I was
completely confident that you would find
nothing to show I knew or believed
anything else as indeed you have not I
was confident not because there's been
some kind of cover-up I was confident
because I knew that is what I believed
and that is why I said it
to understand why I believed it you have
to go back to a time before the Sue gray
report before the police investigation
back to a time where as the evidence
before the committee shows there was a
near Universal belief at number 10 that
the rules and guidance were being
complied with that is the general belief
that has been uncovered by your evidence
and it was that belief that governed
what I said in the house
and as soon as it was clear that I was
wrong and as soon as the sugray
investigation and the metropolitan
police investigation had concluded I
came to the House of Commons and I
corrected the record as I promised I
would
I clearly could not have anticipated the
outcome by coming earlier because I
genuinely did not know what the outcome
would be and was deeply shocked when
fines were issued not least since I had
been told on a couple of occasions at
least by Sue gray that she did not think
the threshold of criminality had been
reached
I believe that the committee's work
helps to explain why I was so shocked
you've been investigating this for more
than 10 months and I thank you for what
you have done you've had access to a
vast body of evidence you have collected
and reviewed hundreds of pages of
transcripts of Sue Gray's interviews and
you have analyzed many thousands of
contemporary emails and WhatsApp
messages and other material
you found nothing
to show that I was warned in advance
that events in number 10 were illegal in
fact nothing to show that anyone raised
anxieties with me about any event
whether before or after it had taken
place
if there had been such anxiety about a
rule-breaking event at number 10 it were
unquestionably have been escalated to me
we all knew how vital it was to maintain
public confidence in the fight against
kovid that we should do what we were
asking the public to do
there's only one exception of course and
that's the testimony of Dominic Cummings
which is unsupported by the documentary
evidence and which plainly cannot be
relied upon he has every motive to lie
not only has the committee found nothing
incriminating it has gathered a huge
amount of evidence which demonstrates
very clearly that those working in
number 10 shared my belief that the
rules and the guidance were being
followed and that I received assurances
that there was no rule breaking a number
10.
the best and fairies course now would be
for the committee to publish all the
evidence it is assembled so that
Parliament and public can judge for
themselves
despite my repeated requests the
committee has refused to do this
as investigator prosecutor judge and
jury it has elected only to publish the
evidence which it considers
incriminating and not the evidence which
I rely on and which answers the charges
and despite assurances that we would be
permitted to add material that we rely
on into the core bundle published today
late last night we were told that the
committee was not willing to publish a
large number of extracts which I rely
upon in my defense that is manifestly
unfair
instead and in the absence of any
evidence that I deliberately misled
Parliament the committee is trying to
mount an argument that I must have known
that the guidance was not being followed
and that I buried and buried in my head
as we were fighting covid was an
unarticulated belief that even if we
were following the rules We Were Somehow
failing to follow the guidance and you
have in your fourth report suggested
that it must have been obvious to me
because you have the photographs so let
me deal with this point head on because
it is nonsense these photos have now
been churned through the media for more
than a year and it seems to be the view
of the committee and sadly many members
of the public that they show me
attending rule-breaking parties where no
one was social distancing they show
nothing of the kind
they show me giving a few words of
thanks at a work event for a departing
colleague they show me with my red box
passing on the way to another meeting
or heading back into my flat to carry on
working often late Into the Night
they show a few people standing together
as permitted by the guidance where full
social distancing is not possible and
where mitigating measures are taken they
show events which I was never fined for
attending
I know the public will have had the
impression that these were covert photos
with their Sinister pixelations that
have been obtained by the media
the vast majority were in fact taken by
the official number 10 photographer
to say that we would have held illicit
events in number 10 while allowing these
events to be immortalized by an official
photographer is staggeringly implausible
there are a couple of photos where the
event is captured on Zoom as well as by
the official photographer which only
reinforces the point if we had an event
with it we believed was illicit or
unauthorized why would we have it on
Zoom when you never quite know who is on
the other side
most important of all if it was obvious
to me that these events were contrary to
the guidance and the rules then it must
have been equally obvious to dozens of
others including the most senior
officials in the country all of them
like me responsible for drawing up the
rules and it must have been obvious to
others in the building including the
current prime minister
order order we will now suspend the city
while to the House of Commons votes and
we will reconvene in 15 minutes thank
you
[Music]
thank you
very much
foreign
order order we will now resume this
evidence session Mr Johnson would you
like to resume your opening statement
yes thank you very much Chad and the
committee will remember I just made the
point about the the photographs and I
I'd asked why on Earth we would have
held illicit or not unauthorized
gatherings in the presence of an
official photographer that I went on to
say most important of all if it was
obvious to me that these events were
contrary to the guidance and the rules
then it must have been equally obvious
to dozens of others including the most
senior officials in the country all of
them most of them like me responsible
for drawing up the rules and it must
have been obvious to others in the
building including the current prime
minister
on the contrary
the overwhelming evidence which you have
assembled is that these individuals
believe that the rules and the guidance
were being complied with and what is so
telling is the number of officials who
say the same thing and the total Silence
of the written or electronic record
about concerns that anyone wanted to
raise with me it will be one thing if
the committee had come here today and
said look here are the emails or here
are the whatsapps that show that you
were warned about rule breaking before
you made your statements to the house
you haven't got any such evidence
because that never happened
but if you now say instead that it must
have been obvious that we were going
against the rules and the guidance then
let's be clear about what you are saying
you're not only accusing me of lying
you're accusing all those civil servants
advisors MPS of lying about what they
believed at the time to be going on
and as far as I know you're not giving
any of them the chance to explain
themselves with their own oral evidence
I don't think you seriously mean to
accuse those individuals of lying and I
don't think you can seriously mean to
accuse me of lying
now everyone knows that there are some
features of this proceeding that are
extremely peculiar are the utmost
respect for you the chair but you've
said some things about this matter
before reading the evidence which are
plainly and wrongly
prejudicial or prejudge the very issue
in which you are adjudicating
I'm going to put your earlier remarks
down to the general cut and thrust of
politics and Trust in what you have
stressed at the outset the impartiality
that the committee insists upon and then
sits upon in your report the committee
is in fact supposed to be inquiring
strictly into what I said about rule
breaking rather than non-statutory
guidance so much of this interrogation
is theoretically irrelevant but I'm
going to take that in my stride because
I I agree with what you said at the
accent it is your job in which I want to
help you to understand why I said what I
said to Parliament and whether I
deliberately set out to deceive and I
emphatically did not
your first concern is that I may have
knowingly or recklessly deceived
Parliament on the first and 8th December
when I said that the rules had not been
broken and the guidance are being
followed completely in number 10.
when I said those words I was not trying
to cover up or conceal anything I said
what I said in good faith based on what
I honestly knew and reasonably believed
at the time
that belief what was in my head
was based on my understanding of the
rules and the guidance
that did not mean that I believed that
social distancing was complied with
perfectly
that is because I and others in the
building did not believe it was
necessary or possible to have a two
meter or one meter after June the 24th
2020 electrified force field around
every human being indeed that is
emphatically not what the guidance
prescribed
it specifically says that social
distancing should be maintained where
Possible having regard to the work
environment and it is clear that in
number 10 we had real difficulties in
both working efficiently and at speed
and in maintaining perfect social
distancing
it's a cramped narrow 18th century
townhouse
we had no choice but to meet day in day
out seven days a week in an unrelenting
battle against covid I had to call many
meetings on the spot and to call a great
mini make a great mini high-speed
decisions
yes we certainly did have social
distancing we avoided physical contact
we gave way to each other in the
corridors and on the stairs we gave each
other as wider birth as we could
but it would have been impossible to
have a drill sergeant measuring the
distance between us all hours of the day
and night so as the guidance prescribed
we had mitigations
when I spoke about the guidance being
followed I was thinking of all the
things we did to stop the spread of
covid given where we were working
we had large numbers of people working
from home we had many meetings at least
partly on Zoom we had limits on the
numbers per room we had sanitizer
dispensers everywhere we had signs on
the walls telling you which way to walk
we kept windows open and we worked
outside as much as possible
because of the particular difficulties
caused by the working environment we had
regular testing and a whole testing
system was set up I believe on the third
floor that went Way Beyond what was
required in the guidance
so if you say how could I stand up in
Parliament and be so categorical
about following the guidance what was I
thinking of
that is what I was thinking of
and I know you will as you've just done
point to the to the photos and then to
the guidance and what I said and you
will say it must have been obvious that
the guidance was being breached but that
is simply not true my beliefs and my
remarks to Parliament were indeed based
on my knowledge of those events but you
have to understand how I saw them and
what I saw During the period I was there
the vast majority of the events relied
upon by the committee are events I
attended for 10 or 15 minutes perhaps a
maximum of 25 in one case to say
farewell to a departing colleague
I know that people around the country
will look at those events and think they
look like the very kind of events that
we or I were forbidding to everyone else
but I will believe till the day I die
that it was my job to thank staff for
what they had done especially during a
crisis like covid which kept coming back
which seemed to have no end and when
people's morale did I'm afraid begin to
sink
but never mind what I think
the more important point is that the
police agreed
they did not find that my attendance at
any of these farewell Gatherings was
against the rules I obviously did not
know at the time that any of these
events later escalated beyond what was
lawful after I left
there is of course one event for which I
and the current prime minister received
fixed penalty notices
but it never occurred to me or I think
the current prime minister at the time
that the event was not in compliance
with the rules and the guidance at about
2 22 pm on the 19th of June 2020 I went
into the cabinet room where I worked
after getting back from a long external
visit I stood at my desk briefly before
another covid meeting began and had a
kind of salad a number of officials came
in to wish me a happy birthday no one
sang the famous Union Jack cake remained
in its tupperware box unnoticed by me
and was later discovered and eaten by my
private secretaries we talked as you
would expect about covid and what we
were doing to beat the pandemic
it is a measure of how innocent we
thought this meeting was that an exagger
or slightly exaggerated version was
briefed to the times with singing and
Cake eating and yet nothing untoward was
apparently detected either by the
reporter or by millions of eagle-eyed
readers so when I spoke to the commons
it did not for one second on the first
or the 8th of December or any time not
one second occur to me that this event
the one event the one event for which I
was fined would later be found to be
somehow against the rules and the same
goes for all the events I attended
my belief was that we were following the
rules and the guidance to the best of
our ability given the circumstances
and that was what the guidance required
you may now say that I was being obtuse
or oblivious and that we should have
enforced social distancing more
ruthlessly and we can argue that back
and forth hindsight is a wonderful thing
we're talking about what I believed at
the time
as for the event of the 18th of December
2020 in The Press Room I was not there
but my honest belief that it was within
the rules was based on what I was told
by senior advisors the fact that this
was my honest belief is supported by the
fact that so many other people honestly
believed that we were doing nothing
wrong and it's abundantly clear from the
evidence produced by the committee that
everyone was operating with the same
understanding of the rules and the
guidance
if you want further evidence of what was
going on in my head look at the WhatsApp
to Jack Doyle where I positively urge
him to get the truth out to the public
the truth out about that December the
18th event it seems so unfair to me
based on what I had been told that the
event was being presented as a purely
social gathering on what I knew to be a
monumentally busy day for the media
department when they were coping both
with the emergence that day of the Kent
variant of kovid and what some saw as
the risk of a No Deal brexit that was
why I was inclined to believe that this
event must be in line with the rules and
the guidance and that's why I said what
I said on December the 1st as for my
statements on December the 8th the
committee is concerned that I may have
misled the house when I said that I was
repeatedly assured that the event was in
accordance with the rules
I don't understand this point you can
see from the evidence that I received
these assurances more than once and from
more than one person my statement was
entirely accurate
the committee criticizes the fact that I
had not received assurances in relation
to the guidance
but I never said that I had I said what
I said about the guidance based on my
own experience and belief
the committee is critical of the fact
that I did not receive reassurances in
respect of any other event any event
other than the December the 18th event
but I never said that I had
the committee seems at times to be
saying in your fourth report that I
should not be relying on the advice of
political advisors or even officials
this is ridiculous I was the Prime
Minister of the UK I was trying to run
the country during a pandemic on the
evening in question 30th of November
2021 I was dealing with the emergence of
the Omicron variant and the growing
clamor for restrictions on another
Christmas I could not drop what I was
doing get up and go and Institute a
personal investigation into what sounded
like a Daily Mirror try on about an
event that was now almost a year old I
had to rely on and was fully entitled to
rely on what I was told by my senior
trusted advisors government would be
paralyzed if ministers were not able to
do so
finally the committee criticizes the
manner in which I corrected the record
I corrected the record on the day of Sue
Gray's final report and six days after
the completion of the police
investigation if the committee's view is
that I should have come to the house and
provided an inevitably incomplete
account while a government or a police
investigation was going on including
into events I hadn't even attended I
fundamentally disagree
at all times I was entirely transparent
with the house
I made it clear that I did not intend to
comment on any of the factual matters
until the investigation had been
concluded I kept the house regularly
updated and as soon as the
investigations were complete I provided
a full correction of my honest but
inadvertently misleading statements
I apologize
I apologize for inadvertently misleading
this house but to say that I did it
recklessly or deliberately is completely
untrue as the evidence shows
whatever we got wrong I believe that
officials in number 10 in the cabinet
office indeed all Whitehall departments
should be immensely proud of their
efforts to protect this country from a
loathsome disease when I point out to
this committee that this disease almost
killed me it's only to stress how
seriously I took the measures we needed
to stop it spreading as I believe
everyone did in number 10 in dining
Street
it was those officials who organized and
took the country through the lockdowns
which whatever people may say about them
now were essential for public health it
was those officials who procured the
vaccines that made sure this was the
first country in the world to put an
approved and effective vaccine in the
arm of a patient and it was those
officials who helped Mastermind the
fastest vaccine rollout in Europe it was
thanks to those officials that we were
able to come out of lockdown faster than
any other European country with all the
social and economic benefits that
entailed and still to have lower excess
mortality or lower excess mortality rate
than many other comparable countries
I'm proud to have known and worked with
those officials during one of the most
difficult times we can remember
I am proud to have given them leadership
and that is what I believe I was doing
at every one of the events in question
and I trust that the committee will be
fair to them fair to me fair to the
evidence about what we and I knew and
believed and conclude that I did not
wittingly mislead the House of Commons
re or recklessly mislead the House of
Commons and that no contempt has been
committed
to our questions uh
the shoe that you raised which your
lawyers wrote to me about uh on Monday
and which I've replied to uh this on
this morning about you raised the issue
of the importance of the committee being
fair to officials and we would very much
agree with you about that and that is
why we're not content with putting into
evidence interview notes that officials
gave to sue gray until such time as
those officials had a chance to check
those interview notes and to agree
whether they're accurate and then they
can be supported by a statement of Truth
which is like an oath and then they can
be put into evidence to us if you would
like to identify some officials and some
aspects of this sugray interview notes
that you would like to then get
understatements of Truth and submit to
this inquiry the inquiry doesn't finish
with this all evidence session you are
perfectly at Liberty to do that and I
would invite you to do that and we can
consider it
um thank you I I I I I will do that
there are about I think they're about 16
points that we we wish to uh to
elucidate and um uh it'll be helpful to
do that okay thank you and we're putting
now in the public domain your lawyer's
letter to me and also my reply to you
this morning so that people can be clear
about that
we'll now begin our questions
starting with those which cover the six
Gatherings that the committee thinks are
the most relevant to our inquiry
when asked in the House of Commons about
gatherings in number 10 from December 21
2021 onwards you told the house that
covid rules and guidance were followed
completely and at all times
following the publication in May 2022 of
the report which you'd commissioned into
Gatherings on government premises you
continue to maintain that it was
certainly the case that the rules and
guidance were followed at Gatherings you
had attended to wish farewell to staff
who were leaving number 10.
we will put to you what the coven rules
and guidance were on those six dates
what you knew about the Gatherings that
took place on each of those dates and
their compliance with the rules and
guidance then in force
we'll start by looking at two leaving
Gatherings that you attended in November
2020.
will primarily be focusing on these
gatherings compliance with the covid
workplace guidance in place at the time
these gatherings took place during a
national lockdown in England the legal
rules in force to prevent the spread of
covid included restrictions on indoor
Gatherings of two or more people
the workplace guidance enforce at that
time
stated that there should be social
distancing of two meters in the
workplace wherever possible
and that only absolutely necessary
participants should physically attend
meetings
I will now invite sir Bernard Jenkin to
ask the first question sir Bernard thank
you chair
um so as the chair described we will
first consider what knowledge you had of
the rules and guidance in place at the
time of each of the events you attended
or of which you had knowledge
by reminding ourselves of what you were
telling the country about the rules and
guidance and then we will ask about
those gatherings
now you were aware of the importance of
following the guidance the government
had issued to keep workplaces safe
indeed you previously told the House of
Commons on the 2nd of September 2020 and
I quote it's very important that we get
people back into the workplace in a
covid secure way unquote and then on the
9th of November 2020 less than a week
before the first of the Gatherings that
I will ask you about you said at a covid
press conference and I quote
neither Mass testing nor progress on
vaccines are at present time for the
present time a substitute for the
national restrictions for social
distancing and all the rest so it is all
the more important to follow the rules
unquote
and at the press conferences over this
period you regularly repeated the phrase
hands face space while standing at
podiums bearing this phrase
so there can be no doubt that you
understood what the guidance and rules
meant and were intended to to achieve
yes or no yes thank you
on the 13th of November 2020 which we
saw Catherine West are just asking about
on the film earlier there was an
impromptu leaving gathering for your
then director of communications Lee Kane
this was held in the vestibule outside
the Press office in number 10.
between 15 and 20 people were present
and you gave a speech
and the evidence for this is at page
nine of the evidence bundle
do you accept that these facts are
correct
uh yes
we will now show the pictures which you
have made your comments about but
nevertheless we will ask you about them
the unpixelated photos are on page 540
and 580 in the bundle of the total
evidence pack
the pictures show you with at least six
to eight other people standing in close
proximity
I want to ask first about these
gatherings compliance with the guidance
you told the House of Commons as
recently as the 25th of May 2022
which was the day of the publication of
the sucre report that it was and I quote
certainly the case strong words
that guidance had been followed at
Gatherings you attended to wish staff
farewell at least yes
but the photographs show a lack of
social distancing of two meters which
was required by the workplace guidance
at the time
could you accept that we're present at
this Gathering and that people were not
socially distanced while you were there
uh thank you very much sir sir Bernard
uh I I don't accept that uh people were
not making an effort to to distance
themselves socially from each other and
that happened uh the whole time in in
number 10. actually I think that the uh
the guidance uh by November uh 2020 uh
stipulated that you should uh maintain
uh uh one meter uh social distancing uh
where possible uh with mitigation where
two meters is not is not viable and at
all at all stages the the guidance was
intended to be uh implemented where
possible
and that is absolutely clear from the
guidance as I said in my in my
introduction I it was always the case
that we understood that the uh the
confine the confines of number 10 we're
going to make it impossible the whole
time to enforce a total uh social
distancing uh as it were with an
electric force field around every
individual now this meeting uh happened
impromptu on an impromptu basis it had
to happen uh it happened because uh on
November the 13th two senior members of
the and people ask you know why was this
happening why was it necessary it was
necessary because two senior members of
Staff uh the uh effective chief of staff
and the director of communications had
both left the building or were about to
leave the building in pretty acrimonious
circumstances or what were potentially
acrimonious circumstances it was
important for me to be there and to give
reassure
and the the Salient point I would uh
venture to make is that following that
Gathering no fine was issued to me my
presence there was felt by the uh by the
Met to be uh
not to be unlawful they agreed that it
was a work-related event and I believe
it was absolutely essential for work
purposes well I'm asking about the
guidance at the moment yes and I'm
telling you that I believe the guidance
is was so what you've got to understand
when I looked at that group it did not
for one second occur to me that we were
in breach of the guidance given the
logistical difficulties we faced in
number 10 and the need to have urgent
meetings such as this and you said uh
you didn't quite answer my question to
begin with because you you suggested
that the picture doesn't show that
people weren't making an effort to
comply with the guidance I'm just asking
whether the evidence is that the
guidance was being complied with and I
think by I believe suggesting I believe
that I believe that the guidance is
being complied right okay because I'll
come to that because
um
it must have occurred to you that given
that they weren't social distancing at
two liters
that they might have been in breach of
the social distancing guidance either
while you were at the Gathering or well
or indeed as you reflected on this
afterwards as the storm broke around
your head you must have been thinking
well I wonder whether that was really
complying with the guidance that must
have occurred so Bernard forgive me but
I've got to correct you on the on the
point of a technical point but after
June uh 20 uh June of 24 2020 uh the
guidance was changed so that uh the
objective was to maintain uh social
distancing uh at uh with at one meter
with mitigations where two meters were
not gone I'll come to that I'll come to
that
but I think the point the first point is
that it's fair to say that you didn't
say that we did every effort to comply
with the guidance the House of Commons
and you didn't say that no I'm saying to
follow the guidance completely because
you can't you okay we'll come to this in
a minute but you you can't
um you can't expect uh human beings in
an environment like uh number 10 uh to
have as it were a
um
invisible electrified fence around them
they will occasionally drift into each
other's orbit when I saw that
it did not mean to me that we had
breached the guidance it means it meant
it meant that we were following the
guidance to the best of our ability
which was what the guidance provided for
and the guidance provides for uh
freedoms within the the Practical
framework of the operation or the
business uh to decide how you're going
to implement the guidance uh the the
measures that you referred to at the
outset are things that need usually uh
to be complied with uh there were
businesses are entitled and asked to
decide what practical considerations
they wish to give to implementing uh the
guidance and and that is what we that is
what we did can I just say so people
understand yes why I believed because
this is the crucial thing if I may say
so
why I believed when I stood up on uh
December the 1st that the guidance was
followed completely at all times what
what picture I had in my head
and why that doesn't conflict with that
that picture the answer is that I knew
from my direct personal experience that
we were doing a huge amount to stop the
spread of covid within the building we
had sanitizers we had uh windows were
were kept open we had people working
Outdoors wherever they could we had Zoom
meetings we had restrictions on a number
of people uh in rooms we had perspex
screens uh between desks and above all
as I said we had testing
regular testing which went Way Beyond
what the guidance prescribed and which
in my view
helped mitigate the difficulties we had
in maintaining perfect social distancing
right I'm bound to say that if you'd
said all that at the time to the House
of Commons we probably wouldn't be
sitting here
but you didn't
and the question is that um the question
is about what the guidance actually says
and I I notice you taking a little
advice at that point on the question of
the guidance can I just read to you or
it's on the page six of the bundle what
the guidance actually says
you must maintain social distancing in
the workplace wherever possible where
the social distancing guidelines cannot
be followed in relation to a particular
activity the businesses should consider
whether that activity be redesigned to
maintain a two meter social distance or
one meter with risk mitigations where
two meters is not viable and the
mitigations mitigating actions include
using screens or barriers to separate
people from each other so where in the
picture is that are there screens or
barriers there were screens or or
barriers in the I believe in the
adjacent uh pressure from memory well
this is a this is a a an impromptu
Gathering which I'm thanking staff
at least one member of staff for his
contribution during covid uh I believe
it was an important part of my job to do
that that was the best place to do it I
accept I accept that perfect social
distancing uh so Bernard is not being
observed but that does not mean that
what we were doing in my view is
incompatible with the guidance the
guidance specifically allows uh for for
workplace freedoms to decide how to
implement it and it and the the up the
operative conditional is where possible
now do not for one moment believe that
people in number 10 did not operate
social distancing because they did and
they took great after they made great
efforts in my uh in my view to my memory
to to to stay apart from each other but
that didn't mean that they they were
able to stay apart from each other the
whole time that's what I'm saying that
did not conflict with the guidance
nobody is devaluing the efforts of
anybody in number 10 during the covet
including you by the way
um and the public service you gave
during your period as prime minister
during the pandemic or were asking us to
I'm afraid it's Our obligation I'm
trying to explain to you why I said the
guidance question through a question
um all I'm saying is we've got to find
out establish in our minds uh whether
what you told the House of Commons was
strictly accurate and the guidance goes
on to say where social distancing
guidelines cannot be followed in full
even through redesigning a particular
activity business should consider
whether that activity needs to continue
for the business to operate and if so
take all the mitigating actions possible
to reduce the effect the risk of
transmission between the staff now
nobody is disputing that it's the right
thing for you to thank your staff
the question is uh whether what you said
about this particular way of thanking
your staff
in the House of Commons was strictly
accurate
um indeed may have been misleading
that's what we're asking well I don't I
don't believe for a second that it was
the guidance does not say uh you can
have a thank you party and as many
people okay if you think it's very
important to thank people the guy just
doesn't say that let's just let's just
let's just go go back over uh over that
uh I I I believed that this event was uh
not only reasonably necessary but it was
essential for work purposes for the
reasons that I have I have given uh the
I've described the constraints in which
we were operating in number 10. uh if
you wanted to have a a rapid Gathering
to thank people this was the place to do
it uh there aren't in fact that many
people uh there I I accept though the
pixelation makes it difficult to work
out uh exactly who is uh who is where I
accept that uh perfect social distance
sure but the public can't see that yeah
the public can't see that yes
I I accept that not everybody is a
perfectly socially distanced in that
picture but that did not mean to me when
I stood up in the House of Commons and
said that the guidance was followed
completely I was not thinking of that
event and thinking that somehow that
contravened the guidance absolutely not
we were we were making a huge effort to
follow the guidance that was my memory
and that is that is why I said what I
said which is exactly the purpose of
this session that you can make the case
that you're making can we move on to
examine the compliance with the covid
rules of this Gathering
as we heard in the clips earlier you
told the house the rules were followed
at all times so you must have thought
the Gathering was reasonably necessary
for work purposes as was then required
by the regulations
we know that the Gathering attracted
fixed penalty notices
so in fact the police have judged that
it broke the rules why did you think it
was within the rules
I thought it was essential for work
purposes or Reason at least reasonably
necessary for work purposes because for
the reason I've given the sir Bernard
that we November the 13th was a day in
which uh two senior officials in those
senior advisors in government uh had
left their jobs in very very difficult
and challenging circumstances and
it was necessary
to steady the ship it was necessary to
show that there was no uh no ranker uh
that uh the business of the government
was being carried on
that's what we had to do that's what I
had to do I know that but it's it's what
you said about it for the House of
Commons is what matters
um we know it was a leaving event for a
member of staff
the photographs we've just seen yes do
not seem to show any actual work being
done uh why did it not occur to you that
it at least might have been in breach of
the regulations at least because it was
not reasonably necessary for work
purposes did you say did it occur to me
that it might not be it reasonably
necessary for workbooks yes no it didn't
occur to me one second okay but it
wasn't reasonably necessary for work
purposes and say that particular thing
about the way that event was actually
carried on and I really you know
to this day and as I as I said earlier
on I
I struggle to see how I could have run
uh number 10 run hundreds of officials
uh who needed to be thanked and
appreciated for their work in very uh
trying circumstances without having a
brief farewell events of a kind that uh
at least insofar as my participation was
concerned did not fall foul of the rules
let's remind you of that key point about
that event I was not uh I was I was
there for a maximum of of 20 minutes or
25 minutes I think uh I gave a a short
speech what I did was not fond of being
in situation at this point because how
long you were at the Gathering it's not
a question I understand that I
understand that Mr Bernard is asking you
and while I'm interjecting you raised
the question of
imperfect social distancing
um social distancing hands face space
which is the space part is either two
meters at this time or it's one meter
with mitigations
two meters two meters where possible
or one meter with litigations which is
where possible so
is to maintain social distancing
wherever possible which is the notion of
a less than perfect and imperfect social
distancing because you were telling yes
country to do social distancing But but
so did we in number 10 and uh but I'm
sure by the way that uh up and down the
country in spite of people's uh
observance of social distancing uh there
were times when people drifted within uh
one or two meters of each other that
that is I'm afraid just inevitable and
um
we had a particular problem in number 10
because as I said earlier on we had to
call meetings at great speed uh we had
large numbers of staff that had to come
into the building because we needed to
uh get a variety of of opinions even
though we had loads and loads of people
also on on zoom and
it was not we had we had as as you know
because you've been to to look at it uh
we had lots of higgledy-piggledy uh
corridors where uh it wasn't and and
spaces where it wasn't always easy to
maintain perfect social distance that
did not mean to like that space there
that did not mean to me
corridors if you could just refer
yourself to Sir Vernon's next question
which is of course an event
um
there were lots of people leading
critical organizations around the
country
and
leaving do for everyone else around the
country was not acceptable under the
guidelines
all the rules so why was it acceptable
and necessary for work purposes in
number 10. thank you sir well I I I look
I I want to repeat what I said at the
beginning I understand the people
looking at that photograph will think
that it looks like a uh a social event
it was not a social event I was if
anybody thinks that I was partying
during lockdown there are they're
completely wrong
that was not a party I was there I
haven't said it was a party Mr Johnson
well you did actually earlier on uh I I
what I what I what I was doing was
thanking staff or thanking one
individual in particular for their
contribution and uh I believe that was
my job
um so if you've been asked at a press
conference with your Podium saying hands
face space space whether it was okay for
organizations to hold unsocially
distanced farewell gatherings in the
workplace what would you have said
I would have said that it's up to
organizations as the guidance says to
decide how and they are going to
implement the guidance amongst which is
of course social distancing where they
can't do social distancing uh perfectly
they can't maintain two meters or one
meters then they're entitled to have
mitigations and that's what the guidance
says and we did indeed have plenty of
mitigations including and as I've said
to you before I this was exceptional in
uh in number 10 we had a great deal of
testing
so the answer is you would have said it
was okay
no I I said the answer is you should do
what the guidance says and the guidance
says that where you where you put in
mitigations uh where you where you do
what is possible uh then uh and where
you follow social distancing in a way
that is uh that reflects the realities
of your workspace uh that will be in
compliance with the guidance that was my
view and I think that's what everybody
else understood so be that just kind of
repeat this point this is what everybody
understood I believe in number 10. it's
for a long period
of of 20 months of the struggle against
covid during which we were having as the
Prime Minister himself has said
describing the experience of walking
into uh loads of of rooms and finding
lots of people there uh it was simply
part of of working in number 10 that we
were going to come into contact uh with
a great number of people but people did
follow social distancing and they they
were acutely conscious of it
I now turn to the 27th of November 2020.
this was another unplanned leaving
gathering for a different special
advisor that again took place in the
vestibule outside the Press office in
number 10.
and we have three witness statements
attesting to a lack of social distancing
at this event
uh we've got and this is on page 17 of
your witness panel uh we've got Jack
Doyle who is your press secretary at the
time and subsequently or director of
communications saying that there were
certainly more than 20 people in
attendance
and do you accept that I I I I I don't
know uh I wasn't at that event and it
wasn't an event that was found of being
in Bridge there's no reason to dispute
it well I I I happen to know because
we've all seen the same evidence uh
bundle though I think this actually this
is one of the things that you have uh
but we haven't been allowed to point to
I think there is I think there is
evidence uh from at least one of the uh
of the participants that uh though there
were there were there weren't that many
uh people now and it lasted a very uh a
very short time
well by all means make sure that's drawn
to our attention oh sorry sorry this is
the clear event uh sorry sorry James I
think I think I think that name that
name we can mention
um
uh my memory of that event uh I think I
was at that event but I was there very
briefly it was going to correct thank
you so I was at that event but I was
there very briefly uh no no uh fines
were issued for that event order order
and pray we have to suspend the
committee again because
15 minutes
I'll resume this evidence session
subverted
um
just on one point you were quibbling
about
um the meaning of the guidance which
does say wherever possible but not in
respect of less than one meter where
mitigations are obligatory uh that's not
wherever possible it doesn't say
mitigations wherever possible they are
essential if you cannot do two meters
and we couldn't see any mitigations in
the photographs but also also
um sorry sorry if I may uh what the
guidance says as far as I can I can see
is it it ensures workers maintain social
distance guidelines or two meters or one
meter with risk mitigations where two
meter is not viable wherever possible
so that that conditional wherever
possible governs both two meters and one
meter okay well we will address that
point in our report we will take
consideration of what you're and the
next but I don't think we agree with
your interpretation of the guidance that
uh well can I say whatever your that's
very important whatever whatever your
interpretation of the guidance May
what matters if I may respectfully say
is what I believed to have been our
efforts to follow the guidance why I
thought that they were credible and uh
wholehearted and what I was thinking of
the time ask you to allow sir Bernard to
ask his next question of course
thank you very much we were talking
about the three witness statements uh or
about the 27th November 2020 event which
was a leading event for another special
advisor in the festival number 10 where
there were certainly more than 20 people
um and I think you accepted that
um
can I come back on that okay certainly
uh I think yeah there's conflicting
evidence on that point and if you look
if you look at what Sue gray has to say
she says 15 to 20. um but we're not
relying on two Gray's evidence isn't
that ironic
um the um
so so are you saying that that evidence
is invalid no I think that any evidence
collected by Sue gray has to be
independently verified with a statement
of Truth which is why we can't publish
the evidence the material which you've
given us which has not been accepted
it's been helpful if I gave my evidence
about it well no I think it'd be very
helpful if there anything in Sue Gray's
witness statements uh that that were
collected in the interview notes would
be dealt with separately as the chairman
described it I think it'd be helpful if
sir Bernard was enabled to ask his
question and you would give a synced
answer
right so on you'll see also on page 17
of your bundle that another witness
stated stated that they couldn't get
through the room to leave because people
were standing four to five people deep
is there any reason why we should
disbelieve that well uh the I've seen
that I've seen all the testimony about
this event and there's testimony from uh
there's the Suga evidence that I I
mentioned and it seems quite incredible
to me that we now can't reduce what she
had to say after extensively
interviewing people she said that were
15 to 20 uh people she thought of that
event it's also the case that the the
person who was leaving on that occasion
uh Cleo Watson I think we can we can
name her uh according to my uh
understanding she said that it was a a a
a a clutch of officials and that it
landed that it it lasted a very short
time indeed and she's and she said I
think that there was a
um a speech by me that lasted 45 seconds
in a speech by her that lasted 15
seconds uh from from memory
um I was certainly there very briefly
indeed and to get to your point
it's about it the the quotation that you
have about that event does not actually
Accord with my my own memory the rich
quotation is this uh of the four to five
people deep and more than 20 people in
in attendance I actually remember quite
as I I my my memory of the event is much
more in line with what Cleo Watson has
to say and what Sue gray had to say
about the event okay
um find it you'll see on page 20 on 17
year old bundle of that another witness
said that you joked during the Gathering
that it was and I quote probably the
most unsocially distanced gathering in
the UK right now unquote a paragraph 63
of your evidence uh your written
submission you do say that you don't
remember saying that those particular
words but I'm therefore denying that you
said this I don't remember saying those
words and I think it's unlikely that I
would have said those words given what
I've had to say to the committee just
now about my memory of the event when I
when I visual memory of the event is
that it was much more as Claire Watson
describes uh it was a clutch of people
around that table the same the same
table that you've just uh been looking
at I don't remember people being four or
five deep I don't remember saying
I'm sorry you're getting very long
answers and it's taking longer than we
need and you're repeating yourself quite
a lot
can we just get on with the questions
thank you very much
um so you you're actually not denying
you said this but you're you can't
recall saying it that's I think unlikely
that I said that but yeah I didn't say
things about social distance you've
answered the question you also state in
your
um written submission of paradise 63 and
I quote that you might well have made
observations in speeches about social
distancing unquote
so what sort of observations I might
well have made observations about the
importance of social distancing since it
was very much on our minds right okay
but how right would it be to conclude
that you can't be sure
what you that you you did not comment on
the lack of social distancing
um and at this or any of the other
Gatherings you attended because
otherwise why would you have raised it
sorry I didn't understand the question
I'm just you're not denying you might
have said that that what I read out I
think I think you know I'm like given
the number of people that I remember see
it
I think it unlikely given the number of
people it would be quite fair to
conclude
that um uh that you did comment on the
lack of social distancing at events
it's quite fast it's certainly likely
that I would have drawn attention to the
importance of social distancing since
that was very high the importance of
social distancing if everyone was about
social distancing obviously it's because
as we've just extensively discussed the
there might be occasions when uh people
gathered together at high speed and
where social distancing was imperfectly
observed well that did not mean that I
thought the guidance was not being
followed but given all that I've said
earlier about observing social
distancing where possible
well you do accept that the evidence we
have under statement of Truth
um that uh indicate that those who were
at this Gathering very clearly indicate
that there was insufficient social
distancing at this Gathering you do
accept that I I say that I some of them
do some of them some of them don't
um and who established that you were
familiar with the social distancing
guidance you were at the Gatherings
there was a lack of social distancing so
it must have been yes obvious to you at
the time and even more obvious on
reflection afterwards as this whole
thing broke around you that it was in
breach of workplace guidance relating to
social distancing
no what uh no that that's not correct
what I thought was that we had done our
best to implement the guidance and in
fact had thoroughly and completely
implemented the guidance but clearly
when it came to things like social
distancing uh as the guidance explicitly
provides for it was not possible at all
times to have perfect social distancing
and and that you could have mitigations
but um as recently as the 25th of May
you said it was certainly the case 25th
of May 2022 last year it was certainly
the case that social distancing social
distancing guidance was being respected
at all times but I think you're now
saying it was imperfect
sorry I'm
trying to do there's a confusion between
social distancing and the guidance
the guidance comprises social distancing
amongst other things
and what we were trying to do was follow
the guidance to the best of our ability
that meant that sometimes social
distancing could not be perfectly
observed there were other mitigations we
put in place
and the guidance also said that only
necessary part visitors participants
should physically attain the workplace
meetings absolutely necessary
participants
usually it said usually when you attempt
when you attended these um events uh
when you didn't even know who was
attending how are you so certain that
everyone there was absolutely necessary
to attend these events
Bernard these events were uh of course
not organized by me personally I relied
upon my excellent officials to make sure
that we had the right people in the room
chat okay thank you
we'll now move on to examine two
Gatherings that took place earlier in
2020 both of which you attended Mr
Johnson we'll look at the Gathering
which took place on the 19th of June
2020. this was a gathering in the
cabinet room to mark your birthday we'll
also look at the Gathering that took
place on the 20th of May 2020 which was
a gathering for staff in the number 10
Garden yeah
the legal rules in force to prevent the
spread of covid varied between May and
June 2020 but at both times the relevant
rules included restrictions on
Gatherings of two or more people the
workplace guidance in Force at that time
stated that there should be social
distancing of two meters in the
workplace wherever possible
and that only absolutely necessary
participants should physically attend
meetings
I'll now invite Yvonne forvard to ask
our questions about these gatherings and
I would ask if you could because we've
already covered quite a lot of ground if
you could answer a succinctly as
possible of course because I may be
repeating when I need to say Thank you
Mr Johnson before I ask my questions can
we again confirm your knowledge of the
rules and guidance in place at the time
by reminding ourselves of what you're
telling the country
you told the House of Commons on the
11th of May that and I quote if you must
go to work and cannot work from home you
you do so provided that your workplace
is covered secure and that you observe
the rules on social distancing
we are publishing further guidance on
that
you also told a house on the 11th of May
that people should be limiting contact
with others and keeping your distance to
two meters apart where possible that was
just a week before the Gathering of the
20th of May
and then on the 10th of June just over a
week before the Gathering of the 19th of
June you said that a covid press
conference I quote I urge everyone to
continue to show restraint and respect
the rules which are designed to keep us
all safe
so please to repeat what you've heard so
many times before stay alert maintain
social distancing and keep washing your
hands
you agree that those were the rules in
Force at the time yes thank you let's
turn first to the Gathering of the 19th
of June 2020 where breaches of both the
covid rules and the guidance are an
issue
we'll show pictures of this gathering on
the screen and the unpixelated photos
are on page 359 and 414 in bundle one of
the total evidence
the pictures show that you attended a
gathering in the cabinet room on this
day to mark your birthday with at least
17 other people in attendance now the
attendees included your wife and your
interior designer didn't they
they certainly included my wife and son
and yes there was a contractor who was
working in the building who popped her
head around the door very briefly
I was just for this event and you've
just confirmed that at least two people
attended who were not work colleagues
why did he think this was reasonably
necessary for work purposes as was
required by the rules at the time but
this was an event that uh took place
as you say on my birthday I come back
from a long uh external visit I thought
it was reasonably necessary for for work
purposes because I was standing at my
desk surrounded by officials who'd been
asked to come and uh wish me a happy
birthday it only recently recovered from
an illness from kovid and it seemed to
me to be uh
uh perfectly proper thing to do you're
about to have another meeting and they
were very largely the same officials
and presumably your wife and the
contractor were not attending that
meeting
it is one of the peculiarities of number
10 that my the Prime Minister and his
family live in the same building and uh
it it
my understanding of the rules is that uh
the process family is entitled to to use
that building and use every part of that
building
turning now to the guidance in respect
of that event the covered workplace
guidance then in place said that
workplace meetings should be socially
distanced and only attended by those
whose participation was absolutely
necessary
now the two pictures we see on the
screen show the Gathering wasn't
socially distanced and it was attended
by people who were not absolutely
necessary to be there so would it not
have been obvious to you that the event
was in breach of the garden no and it's
a measure of how unobvious it was to me
uh that this was any kind of breach at
all that we actually or the press-off is
actually publicized this meeting in the
Times newspaper briefed it out as I said
earlier on with a slightly embellished
account
I can I I had absolutely no sense while
this event was taking place and indeed
uh later on at any time that this event
was in contravention of either the rules
or the guidance nor did anybody before I
spoke in the House of Commons
suggest to me that it was and I think
that the then chancellor who also
received an fpn would have been just as
surprised as I was
so you didn't reflect on the event
afterwards as to whenever it was in both
rules and guidance before he spoke in
the House of Commons no I I didn't and
and that's because it was a long time
ago I'm afraid it had entirely slip my
mind and I thought it was a completely
innocent event it was a very brief event
uh I'm I'm standing at the desk I uh at
the the place I would have normally sat
uh it did not strike me as being
anything other than an ordinary commonly
Garden workplace event
gathering in the number 10 Garden for
staff with evidence that you're present
at this Gathering while you were there
there were up to 40 people also there
and at this time a gathering had to be
essential for work purposes to be within
the regulations
now we've got evidence that the email
invitation for this Gathering which was
sent by a principal private secretary
Martin Reynolds was sent to 200 odd
people and that it encouraged staff who
attended to bring their own alcohol
that's on page 35 of your bundle did you
see the invitation email at any time
before it was made public no
you didn't see the email itself but were
you aware that the email was sent to 200
on people and invited stuff they're an
alcohol so what was your understanding
of the purpose of the Gathering
to thank staff who had been working very
hard on covid and uh it seemed to me and
I think I was told about it only shortly
before it uh before I was I should add
into it the purpose of it was to uh to
thank them in in a uh obviously a
ventilated area
the god
did you discuss
any official
official yes I think I would have been
told
um I mean I don't remember it but I
think I would have been told uh that the
Kobe team is gathering outside uh it's
been a very tough time uh this was a day
when the cabinet secretary had just uh
stepped down uh I think the civil
servants needed to feel that as I said
in respect of another event uh the the
business and government was being
carried on and they needed to be just to
feel thanked and motivated for their
work and that's what I did
before it took place
um briefly yes but I think I it was you
know one of those
things where as I think Sue gray May
point out in her report I don't know
what value we now attached to it uh but
uh when your prime minister you you move
around quite rightly your officials uh
give you uh the next thing to do and you
go and do it and this was this was the
next thing to do I then went and had a
telephone audience with uh with her
majesty
with evidence that some officials and
advisors felt the event shouldn't go
ahead on page 34 of your bundle
the event director of communications Lee
Kane describes the tone of the email
invitation as clearly social and in
breach of covid guidance and said he
rose concern about it with Martin
Reynolds another official gave us
evidence saying and I quote I heard
there were so many people who are
unhappy about the party that they were
not going to go and they themselves said
to another official that they thought it
was Magnus that evidence is on page 38
of your bundle were any concerns about
the governing's compliance with covid
rules or guidance raised directly with
you at the time no and the individual
that you mentioned who raised concerns
uh lee uh
was if you read what he says he was he
was concerned about the Optics not about
the rules and he himself attended the
event and certainly no concerns will
raise with me the event had been within
the rules why were you concerned about
the Optics
I I think I can't say I think he was
concerned about the impression that
people might gain if they looked over uh
the Garden Wall if they were coming from
the uh the the media uh Roman and
thought that we were doing something
that other people weren't allowed to do
and I in my opening
um remarks I made clear that I can see
why people might have felt that way but
I as I told the house uh when I came to
report on that event I I still believe
it was within the guidance and within
the rules the diddly came discuss or
raise concerns about the gathering with
you at the time and his evidence
suggests he might have done he said I
quote I don't recall if I personally had
a conversation with the PM about the
garden party but it would have been
highly unusual for me not to have raised
a potentially serious Communications
risk with the piano and if he had
thought and his and if he had thought
and if Dominic Cummings had thought that
this thing really was against the rules
and should not go ahead they would have
told Martin Reynolds and it is
inconceivable that it would have gone
ahead
Martin Reynolds discuss or raise any
concerns about the gathering with any
other time and it again is evidence yes
to us he may well have done he said it's
possibly raised concerns with you
no not that I can remember now
will you otherwise aware of any concerns
from what you've heard or read either
before or after the government took
place no as I said as I told the House
of Commons about and I gave a quite a
long series of remarks about this event
when I walked out into the into the God
and it seemed to me implicit it was
implicit in what we were doing that this
was a work event
as we'll see from Pages 34 40 and 41 of
your bundle we have evidence that
Trestle tables are set up on which
alcohol was laid out and that the
attendees included your wife as well as
advisors who were not from number 10 but
from other government departments did
you see that when you're at the
Gathering I I had no hand in organizing
this with about Trestle tables and and
so on it was I I I I I and there's no
prohibition sorry
tables with the alcohol on it
she was asking whether you saw the
Trestle tables with the I did see I did
see I don't remember uh what exactly was
on The Trestle tables I I remember going
around and thanking staff for what they
were doing during covid now it is
perfectly possible that my wife was in
the garden as well but she's was
entitled to be there I don't she
certainly didn't receive a fixed penalty
notice for that event nor did I
also see from page 34
it was a purely social function did you
share that view no then that's certainly
not what he said at the time because if
he thought that it was purely social and
therefore against the rules it is
inconceivable that it would have gone
ahead
the Metropolitan Police have confirmed
that fixed penalty notices were issued
in relation to that Gathering so we know
it breached the covid regulations we
know that you knew what the regulations
were and we know you were in attendance
so it would have been obvious to you
when you were there that the Gathering
was not essential for work purposes and
was partially a social event wouldn't it
no and I actually I if I'm if I'm of
great respect uh I want to dispute the
idea that it was uh not an essential
Gathering or a gathering that was
reasonably necessary for work purposes I
don't know why the fpns were issued but
it may be that they were issued to
people who had not a good enough reason
to come in from home uh to that
Gathering or people who had come from
elsewhere to that Gathering but my my
firm impression I think you'd certainly
still the case that Martin Reynolds
believes that that Gathering was within
the rules and indeed within the guidance
country if they'd asked you at one of
the press conferences at that time to
have a large social gathering in their
Garden it was not a large social
Gathering it was it was it was a
gathering intended and I really must
insist on this point
people who say that we were partying in
lockdown simply do not know what they
are talking about
people who say that that event was a
purely social Gathering are quite wrong
my my purpose there was to thank staff
to motivate them in what had been a very
difficult time and what was
also a very difficult day which is a
cabinet secretary had just resigned
does it accept
and to work
shall distancing guidelines that didn't
apply to the hospitals and the care
homes workplaces that were also
operating on were incredibly different
difficult and challenging circumstances
of course not and that's why we
continued that's why we had all the
stipulations that I've discussed at
Great length with suburbanon about about
following the guidance
thank you Mr Johnson back to the chair
thank you
um to complete this section of our
questions we'll look at two Gatherings
that took place at the end of 2020 in
the start of 2021. the first we'll look
at took place on the 14th of January
2021 that was a leaving gathering for
two officials held in the pillared room
of Number 10. the next one we'll look at
was a Christmas gathering in the
vestibule on the 18th of December 2020
at the time of both Gatherings the legal
rules in force to prevent the spread of
alcohol spread of covid included
restrictions on Gatherings of two or
more people and workplace guidance
stated that there should be social
distancing of two meters in the
workplace wherever possible and that
only absolutely necessary participants
should physically attend meetings I'll
invite Alan dorens to ask you about
these gatherings Mr Doris thank you good
afternoon Mr Johnson
Mr Jones before I ask my questions can
we again confirm your knowledge of the
rules engagements in place at that time
by reminding yourself of what you are
telling the country
you told House of Commons on the 2nd of
September that it was very important
that we get people back into the
workplace in a covered secure way
this shows you're aware of the workplace
guidance and its contents
then on the 9th of November you said
that a covert press conference that
neither much testing nor progress on
vaccines are at the present time of
substitute for National restrictions for
social distancing and all the rest so it
is all the more important that we follow
the rules
in addition at the first conference on
the 30th of December you outlined a tier
4 restriction which were enforced in
London a fortnight later on the 14th of
January Gathering took place you said
the reception meant not meeting up with
friends or family and doors unless they
are in the same household or support
bubble and avoiding large Gatherings of
any kind
my first question to you is that your
understanding of the division yes thank
you thank you my first question will
concentrate on the Gathering of the 14th
of January 2021.
this was a living event for two
officials held in the pilgrim at number
10. we have evidence that approximately
15 people attended we will now show you
a picture of this gathering on the
screen
the unpixelated photo is in page 757 of
bundle 2 of the total evidence
here we see that the picture under the
screen Mr Johnson the photograph shows
yourself and at least other people 11
other people in attendance in the
unpixelated picture
the Metropolitan Police have confirmed
fixed penalty notice were issued to some
individuals who attended this Gathering
as it breached the covert regulations in
place at the time
and was not reasonably necessary for
work
this bridge in the covered rules which
have been obvious to you when you were
there wouldn't it no I I must
respectfully disagree with you very
strongly Mr dorans uh on the contrary
what I see there is a and I I know that
there's a some some bottles on the on
the table but you have that a you're
looking actually I think that's a zoom
that's somebody that's somebody a
screenshot taken from from Zoom I would
guess because you've got people uh at
this event a large number of of the
people uh were actually on Zoom you've
got people who work with each other
every day who use that uh room for
meetings and who are meeting briefly to
say thank you and and farewell to I
think too talented uh young uh officials
I think Malcolm Reed and Alex Burns uh
was the was the was the occasional
um and uh it was the sorry forgive me I
shouldn't I shouldn't I shouldn't
mention the names of the of the official
I said they're talented but anyway uh
those two those two officials were uh
leaving and it was my job to thank them
and to show that their work was
appreciated uh I was there very briefly
I didn't receive a an fpn there's
nothing I can see and I gotta tell you
there's nothing I can see in that uh
photograph that strikes me as being
either against the rules or the guidance
and I I would actually what I actually
see and and depending on how you your
your perspective is what I actually see
is is people trying to stay reasonably
far apart from each other that's that's
what I see now I don't know what
happened later on but I can tell you
that for the period I was there it
seemed to me to be holy in accordance
with the uh the rules and the guidance
and a a proper use of my time even if it
was only brief
would you agree with
the dip from an official who attended
and who described a gathering as not
strictly an event about work this
statement is on page 47 of your evidence
well I I I I I don't agree with that
because I think that it was essential to
thank staff throughout the the pandemic
there weren't very many of these
occasions uh when they when they
occurred I thought it was right and
proper for me to to motivate staff by
saying how we were doing and to thank
them for what they've done it wasn't
just the staff who were leaving who
needed to be appreciated it was the
staff who were there who needed to be
motivated
thank you the picture shows uh this
Gathering it appears to show multiple
bottles of alcohol in the bottom right
hand corner of the photograph
would you say that that is strictly
necessary for a work event
it's it's customary to a safer world to
people in this country with a a toast I
didn't see any sign of drunkenness or or
excess and uh had no knowledge of I
don't know why anybody would have been
fined for that event I don't know what
what happened later on
uh the next kind of thing we want to ask
you about is a gathering on the 18th of
December 2020 but if you know was not
compliant with code regulations some
attendees received fixed penalty tickets
this Gathering was a pre-planned press
office drinks event with cheese and wine
and was widely reported in the Press
we have evidence that it was attended by
between 25 and 40 people
you'll find the relevant statements on
page 54 of your revenues candle
your official diary confirms that you're
intend only Fleet that evening
did you attend team join this Gathering
no
18th of December I'm sorry the 18th of
December 25th absolutely no okay
um your official diary on page 56 so
they have this blender shows a gap
between the hours of 1917 and 2024 and I
appreciate this is difficult but can you
confirm where you were at that time
uh I imagine I was working I think from
from memory there was a this was this
was an evening when we were dealing not
just with the emergence of the uh the
Kent variant uh with with Delta I think
it was uh but also with a great deal of
anxiety about uh whether we were going
to have a a no deal brexit I I thought
that anxiety was unfounded of course uh
and and we didn't but it was a a very
long and very difficult evening I think
we had a an extended covido uh session
but I certainly did not attend that
event and have had no direct knowledge
of it
okay thank you we conducted the
Privileges committee conducted a visit
to turn down your feet as you know
we established you can clearly see from
the suppressed vegetable
where this Gathering was taking place
from the bottom of the stairs leading up
to then what was your flight in Downing
Street
your diary says you went to your flight
at 2158
apparently Gathering went on until after
midnight
is your evidence that you did not see or
hear the noise of a counting about 25 to
40 people taking place in the vegetable
room a vegetable when you're going to a
flat if we just perhaps explain there is
a corridor a narrow corridor leading to
the vegetable before you get to it the
staircase on the left leads to your
flight
your direct line of sight would be
intervestable not more than a few meters
away there's a gathering taking place
with between 25 and 40 people you had
clear direct line of sight of that that
room are you telling me that your
evidence is that you're not aware of the
noise or the event taking place
absolutely and all I what I would have
uh if I if I had looked uh what I would
have seen I'm sure was people
doing a huge amount of work to on a very
very busy evening now I I didn't I
didn't look I suddenly have no memory of
of seeing any kind of
um party or or illicit Gathering going
on in The Press Room on that evening the
first time the first I heard about this
thing the first I knew about it was when
um it was brought to my uh attention by
Jack Doyle I think almost almost a year
later
you will see that this Gathering was
described and evidence we've received as
beyond their strengths and far more
relaxed than it should have been where
people were sure not to shoulder with
each other and that one number 10 staff
member did not attend said the letter
held that the Gathering had turned into
a party did anyone tell you about that
well there's no they didn't and this is
the crucial Point nobody raised the any
anxieties about that event with me uh
before I stood up in the House of
Commons nobody said to me that we we've
had something uh that we've done
something that in in the almost a year
that followed between uh December the
18th 2020 and 30th of November uh 2021
uh when Jack Doyle came to see me the
thing was a complete blank to me right
yeah the Red Bull and police are
confirmed fixed penalty notice were
issued to some attendees at that
Gathering
clearly therefore it breached the rules
there are no witness to say that you
were at the Gathering
but didn't we make you aware at the time
or after happened that had not been
compliant with covered rules no
okay
Mr Jones before we move on to discuss
what you said in the house about
Gatherings at number 10
you will know that fixed power to
tickets were issued in relation to
Gathering is number 10 on two other days
other than noise we've asked you about
these gatherings took place on the 17th
of December 2020 and the 16th of April
this is confirmed by the Metropolitan
Police statement at the end of operation
Hillman which you'll find the coffee
over on page 89 and 91 of your evidence
bundle
did you ever have any reason to think
that covered Wheels may have been broken
at this Gathering or in either of these
dates prior to 2021 you know December
2021. so which which states forgive me
17th of December and the 16th of April
what I can tell the committee is
none of these I was conscious of none of
these events as being in any way rule
breaking or against the guidance until
stories started to emerge about them and
that was after I had spoken in the uh in
the comments about them so they were
they weren't at all on my radar as
things that we that I should be
concerned about
thank you Mr you have to hand you back
to the chair
guidance relating to covid that were
enforced at the time of the Gatherings
we've discussed with you
considered your knowledge of the rules
and guidance then enforce and we've
considered your attendance at a
knowledge of gatherings that were not
socially distanced and for which fixed
penalty notices were issued
pair that with what you said to the
House of Commons after media reports of
these gatherings began emerging we'll
concentrate particularly on what you
said to the house on the 1st of December
and the 8th of December
we'll first examine your assertions that
covid rules and guidance were followed
in number 10 and I'd like to invite Andy
Carter to ask our questions about this
thank you chair Mr Johnson
um on the afternoon of the 30th of
November I understand the Daily Mirror
contacted the Press office at Downing
Street saying they were planning to
publish an article edging that events
had taken place in Downing Street in
November and December 2020 where covered
rules have been broken
now the article appeared online later
that day and uh it was the paper's front
page Splash on the 1st of December and I
think uh you can see a copy of that on
page 58 in your evidence bundle
um I'm guessing you must have known that
you would be asked about this at Prime
Minister's questions in the House of
Commons uh the the following day the the
um the first of uh December and sure
enough you were you were asked whether a
Christmas party was held in number 10 on
the 18th of December and you told the
house all guidance was followed
completely in number 10. picking up on
the things that you've said in your
opening statement and the evidence that
you've given you knew what the guidance
was are you maintaining social
distancing wherever possible uh ensuring
mitigation was in place if that wasn't
possible and you knew the bean
Gatherings where social distancing
hadn't necessarily been maintained and
wear masks for example weren't being
warm and screams weren't in in place
because we've seen some of the the
photographs there so why did you tell
the house all guidance was followed
completely in number 10.
thank you so I'm not certain that there
was any just quickly I'm not certain
there's any requirement for masks uh
indoors after mitigation I see I'm with
you okay so the reason I said that all
guidance was followed completely in
number 10 and you know to back to Mr Mr
dorans and the general a lot of the
questions that have been raised
between
that the the event that took place and
when I stood up to to speak
in in all the cases that I that uh that
you've mentioned nobody came to me and
said uh we've got a problem with this
one uh you need to you need to worry
about this and I want you to I want you
to and there's no trace of that in the
written evidence or in the uh in the
electronic record and that is a very
extraordinary thing uh given how serious
that was the reason I said what I said
uh was because I thought I believe then
uh that the
the whole of the number 10
team we're doing a huge amount to follow
the guidance and uh I I talked to Jack
Doyle about what had happened uh at that
event this is on the evening of the the
30th of November uh 2021.
and it's about uh I'm not my diary says
it was about six o'clock uh he comes in
and uh he says that the as you say the
Daily Mirror is going to run this story
uh he mentions a few other uh events
um two of which I I knew directly about
and knew that there was no uh as I as I
believed at the time I knew that there
was no issue with those the other was
something I think there was something to
do with an event at CCH conservative so
an officer I knew absolutely nothing
about
um I asked him about this December 18th
event
and I said I asked him to describe it
and bear in mind everything I said about
that evening which was a a horrendously
busy and difficult evening and we'd had
a long uh covered out to discuss what to
do uh with with the Kent variant
um
he told me that it was within the rules
uh he said that people were sitting at
their desks
uh
drinking uh admittedly but that was not
banned that was under any of the either
the rules or the or the guidance it was
not very bad it was regular I'm afraid
for people to uh to drink it on Fridays
um
and I concluded that it sounded to me as
though that event was within both the
rules and the guidance
and
that 45 million in what I stood up to
say the following day as it happens
when I said the guidance has been
followed completely during number 10
which is actually what I said
um I I was misremembering the the line
that had already been put out to the
media about this event which was covered
rules were followed at all times but
you've got to understand that I didn't
think that
there was any real distinction from The
public's point of view between the rules
and the guidance in the sense that or
our observance of let me put it this way
I didn't think that the public would
make any they would expect us to follow
the guidance as much as as the rules and
so that's why and and so even though I I
said something slightly different I
still believe it was true can I just if
you said something slightly different
can I ask you why didn't you correct the
record then because that would have been
an obvious thing to do no and I
understand the point you make there is
confusion between guidance and rules but
yeah I could have corrected the record
at that point but I I I I I I didn't
think there was any appreciable
difference because it was our job to
follow the guidance as much as to follow
the rules and My Views I've as I've said
repeatedly to the committee this
afternoon is that I believe we were
following the guidance and in spite of
the uh the pictures that we've all
looked at which which seemed to show a
lack of perfect social distancing I
believe that what we were doing was in
Conformity uh with the rules for the
certainly was for the period I was there
and I believe that the behavior was
reasonable uh given the constraints of
the building and therefore in accordance
with the guidance so that's why what I
said what I said I know you didn't
attend the the Gathering on the 18th of
December you you've just been being very
clear about that
um but you have attended some of the
other Gatherings that we've talked about
um and you've just said that you asked
Lee Kings to Kane about the Gathering on
the 18th so why didn't you tell the
house uh at that point um when you were
asked that there were some of the
gatherings in number 10.
I told uh I said it was Jack dollar I'm
sorry but
um
but because
and the you know this goes to the heart
of what we're trying to establish I
didn't think that those events were an
issue nobody had previously raised them
with me as being the things that I ought
to be concerned about and
they didn't and as I've as I've said
repeatedly to the to you at the time
call me uh obtuse or oblivious but they
did not seem to me to be in conflict
with the rules or the guidance as we
were trying to implementing in number
10. okay the next prime minister's
question was on the 8th of December a
week later
I think it probably would have been fair
to say that you would have guessed that
the topic would have been brought up
again by the the leader of the
opposition
um because uh the previous evening ITV
had published a video of a mock press
conference where numbers number 10 staff
were were seemingly joking about the
Gatherings on the 18th of December
um pmq is on the 8th of December you
were asked if there was a party in
number 10 on the 13th of November and
you told the house the guidance was
followed and the rules were followed in
Downing Street at all times
by the 8th of December it'd been a full
week since you were first asked in the
house about gatherings in Number 10. the
issue had continued to feature on the
front page of many of the newspapers and
as we later saw on on the television
what did you do in that week to prepare
for any further questions about
Gatherings to decide whether you needed
to correct your previous statement that
the guidance had been followed and
whether you should reaffirm it well I
did as a committee knows I did the most
the the most obvious thing which was uh
when the the Allegra video uh emerged on
the uh the evening of I think the uh the
seventh of uh December I decided that
I was getting conflicting information
about what had happened at this
gathering on the 18th of December
um I was troubled by that I hadn't been
at the thing I was relying on what I
thought were the honest and
well-intentioned descriptions of this
from uh my my trusted advisors but
clearly there was a difference of
opinion so I commissioned the cabinet
secretary to conduct an inquiry that's
the most important thing that I did
by the end of that prime minister's
questions on the 8th of December you've
been asked I think multiple times about
the issue of gatherings in in Downing
Street but at no point did you tell the
house that you knew that there have been
Gatherings that you had attended in
particular the five we've raised with
you why did you fail to tell the house
on the 8th of December that there were
Gatherings that you'd attended but Mr
Carter you've got it you've got to
understand that uh in my mind at the
time these did not seem to me to be
improper or offensive events so that I
they did not they weren't in my
Consciousness because I
I thought they were work events as I
said to the house when we came to
discuss the May 20th event and I came to
the house uh to explain I I made it very
clear that I thought that that was a
work event and then indeed I still do
having told the house on the 8th of
December that the guidance was followed
and the rules were followed at all times
in Downing streets you then reiterated
this the following month you told the
house prime minister's questions on
January the 12th I believe that the
events in question were within the
guidance and were within the rules you
knew what the rules and guidance were
and you personally attended at least
four Gatherings those of the 20th of May
the 19th of June the 13th of November
and the 14th of January 2021 for which
fixed penalty notices were issued to
attendees which hadn't been compliant
with the rules and at which breaches of
the rules and guidance must have been
obvious to you because
you were there so so no uh so the uh the
only fpn that I received uh was for the
event that I uh We've we've been over in
some detail which was the the the the
event in the cabinet room and I think
that uh even this committee I I I you
know I venture to suggest might concede
that had they been in my shoes at that
event it might not have occurred even to
them uh that this was a an event that
was against either the rules or the
guidance it certainly didn't occur to me
it didn't occur to the then Chancellor
of the exchequer it didn't occur to the
media Department we agreed to that that
was anyway that was the only event for
which I received an fpn all the other
events uh for the period I was there I
can only conclude were deemed by the uh
met to be not rule breaking events
because I wasn't issued with an fpn
therefore you have two sets of events
the one the for which I received an fpn
which boggled my mind because I couldn't
understand why I got it and and the
others uh where I I wasn't aware of rule
breaking at the time and believed we
were following the guidance so there was
nothing I could say to the house on that
school
you sent to page 61 of the evidence
bundle you can see a statement there
from the then principal private
secretary Martin Reynolds in which he
says that he directly questioned with
you whether it was realistic to argue
that guidance had been followed at all
times in number 10 do you accept that
you were advised not to say guidance was
followed at all times in number 10 and
yet you told the house that it was on
the 8th of December and the 12th of
January so on the there's a couple of of
important points uh it is absolutely
true that Martin Reynolds was cautious
about what I should say in the house on
the 8th of December because we'd already
begun uh the process of the inquiry we
were looking at the uh the December the
18th event I had received assurances
about uh the rules on December the 18th
but I hadn't received assurances about
the guidance what what Martin was trying
to get at if you look at his uh what he
says it's it's clear he's talking about
social distancing and whether it was uh
whether we had maintained social
distancing within number 10 and whether
that would uh that would be whether we
had maintain perfect social distancing
within number 10 and if you look at uh
paragraph
um
um Martin makes it clear that he thinks
that the nature of the working
environment
in number 10 uh might make it uh
difficult to claim that full social
distancing uh was observed that that so
forgive me just spend while the bell's
ringing we don't need to vote but sorry
okay
it's a very very important point it just
goes to the heart of I think the
confusion
and what works in in his
comments to me
Martin is is talking about whether or
not we observed
perfect social distancing he is not
saying that we did not observe the
guidance and I can
prove that if you've just reflect for a
second on what it would mean if you had
said that throughout the pandemic we
were not observing the guidance he
didn't mean that uh he and I were
responsible for making sure that we were
observing the guidance to the best of
our ability if you'd asked Simon case or
any of the senior officials uh were we
following the police the other way
around were you floating the guidance in
number 10 they'd have said no we were
following the guidance but with
mitigations uh and uh with
um social distancing where possible as
specified in the guidance
on reflection and and given that Mr
Reynolds says that you agreed to delete
the reference to guidance do you wish
you'd have corrected the ref the record
at that point
no because uh
first of all we'd already begun the uh
the inquiry and I it was I didn't know
what to I didn't know what sense the
guidance had been uh broken I didn't
know that I didn't I had no evidence
that anybody had had broken the guidance
it wasn't clear to me what I would say
uh to the House of Commons
um the second nobody had nobody was
advising me to uh to correct uh the
record and
um
Martin and I as I've tried to explain
we're talking about two different things
I was talking about
the totality of following the guidance
he was talking about maintaining perfect
social distancing uh the advice that he
was giving me was in relation to a
statement that I was making about the
December the 18th event and about the
reassurances I had received and it was
true to say that I'd received
reassurances about that event uh as far
as the rules went uh but it was also
true to say that nobody had explicitly
reassured me about the guidance and he
thought it prudent
to take out the reference to the
guidance either it is true this as you
just said Mr Carter I then went on to
later in pmqs to talk to Catherine West
I don't know when everybody was going to
come to this point but uh she asked her
a question
and as you as you've as you've said I
said that the uh she asked the question
whether there had been a party on
November the 13th I said no but I was
sure that the rules and guidance had
been observed uh what I said no but
whatever happened I was sure that the
rules and guidance have been deserved at
all times and I I said that with
confidence because I knew about the
events he was talking about on November
the 13th and had my own personal reasons
to believe that that was true
statement to us paragraph 81 too uh you
say you don't believe that perfect
compliance with social distancing was
required by the guidance
yes
what make it clear when you told the
house that the guidance was followed at
all times
well that's a very good question
um Mr Carter and perhaps it would have
been
um
perhaps it would have as I think sir
Bernard said earlier on
um perhaps if if I'd elucidated more
clearly what I meant and what I felt and
believed about uh following the guidance
uh
that would have helped
probably final question paragraph 28 of
your submission you quote an excerpt
from the workplace guidance which says
where the social distancing guidelines
cannot be followed in full in relation
to a particular activity business should
consider whether that activity needs to
continue for the business to operate and
if so take all the mitigating actions
possible to reduce the risk of
transmission are you saying you thought
these gatherings were so critical to the
function of government that it was
permissible to hold them even if they
couldn't be socially distant uh the
short answer is yes I thought that it
was essential to thank staff for their
work I think that
even though the the pictures seem to
show uh festive events I think that our
efforts even in those pictures are being
made to uh to do social distancing and
what I saw what I had in my head when I
was talking to the House of Commons was
a memory a strong memory of people over
a long period doing everything they
could to stop the spread of disease
within the building and just so we're
clear
at those events in the vestibular the
first pictures we saw what mitigations
were put in place that were required by
the guidance
so uh I I've I've listed some of them
but uh we
avoided physical contact we we didn't
for instance as the guide and says we
didn't touch each other's pens uh we
didn't pass uh stuff to to each other if
we could if we could possibly uh avoid
it
um we kept we kept
I would not wish to say that that was
perfectly people were passing drinks to
each other because we've seen the
picture of course and I'm not good and
this is guidance
this is guidance and I'm not going to
pretend that uh
it was uh enforced rigidly but that's
explicitly what the guidance provides
for uh we had Zoom meetings we had a
great reduction in the numbers of people
in the in the building overall we had
signs telling you which way to to walk
uh we had perspex screens and I've
mentioned all this before but it's worth
it really is worth going over again
because it's asking you about that
specific event
when you see the photographs in the
vestibule none of those mitigations seem
to be evident
yes because so which event are you
talking about Mr the first photographs
that we saw Yes okay the November the
30th the Lee Kane event yes and that is
because uh
that was the space where people
congregated fast uh if I wanted to get a
message out it was the the natural place
to to do it uh
yes you don't see
um you don't see
um uh perspex screens there but that
doesn't mean that there wasn't uh
sanitizer uh and efforts to to to to
restrict the spread of covet final
question for me and just sort of you
know just in all of this
bear in mind that we believed Martin
Reynolds believed everybody responsible
for the health of the building and the
health of employees in the building
believe that the uh guidance was being
very considerably augmented in a way
that went beyond the guidance by the
testing regime that I've I've described
I I don't think any members of this
committee don't recognize the challenges
that you were facing the team were were
facing in Downing Street and uh the the
steps that were being put in place to
try and keep people safe I I do though
want to just finish if I may with the
um the comment that you made to the
house on the 12th of January that you
believed implicitly that the Gatherings
of the 20th of May which you attended
had been a work event that was the event
in in the garden I mean it's being
termed it was termed in the press to
bring your own booze it was a garden
party
um many are suggesting that was clearly
not essential for work purposes and
they're therefore in breach of the the
covered rules at the time why did you
say that to the house
because I I as I I implicitly believe
that it was a work event and as I said
to to the committee just now
I was I was ushered out into the garden
having been briefed a shortly beforehand
about what the event entailed uh I I met
and thanked various groups of people who
had been working on Covert you see the
numbers are calculated between 10 and
and 30 or 40. I I couldn't say exactly
how many were there but it was I thought
an appropriate use of the of the garden
uh I felt it was an obvious work event
but what I said to sue gray afterwards
if you can if we can mention uh Sue Gray
camera chair well I said to sue gray was
that um
when I looked back at that event this is
what I was what I was what I what I what
I said to is why I said what I said to
the house
you know I tried to put myself in the in
the in the place of somebody a member of
the public Looking Over the Garden Wall
and seeing that and I had to accept that
even though
it was I believe within the guidance and
within the rules I have to accept that
members of the public looking at it
would have thought that looks to me like
something that he's not allowing us to
do and I felt that very
keenly in in retrospect
I didn't the the I didn't feel it at the
time
do you see what I'm trying to say I
understand that can I can I ask you one
further question I think probably all
MPS that have been on
um on on days where we're very busy
going from meeting to meeting rely on
our advisors to guide us through where
we're going I understand what you said
about that as the Prime Minister working
on a busy schedule did you at any point
question any of the events that you were
going to when the advisors were taking
you to them I look at hindsight's a
wonderful thing uh in retrospect I I
might have thought about uh some things
you know
a post post suede poster uh the the
beginning of the of the of the coming to
light of everything that uh did come
right I have thought about it but
um no at the time I thought we were
working I thought we were working and
that is what I promise you that is what
officials uh in number 10 thought they
were doing as well thank you very much
Mr Johnson
um can we now turn to the issue of the
assurances that you uh mentioned to the
house on numerous occasions and I'd like
to ask um Alberto Costa to ask you uh
the committee's questions on the issue
of the assurances thank you cheers good
afternoon Mr Johnson thank you very much
for coming before this important inquiry
I'm very grateful could I invite the
team to place up slide number eight
please
Mr Johnson as we've just seen on the
screen on the 8th of December 2021 in
your opening remarks at Prime Minister's
questions you told the house that and I
quote I've been repeatedly assured since
these allegations emerged that there was
no party and that no covered rules were
broken
in response to subsequent questions you
said that quote I've been repeatedly
assured that the rules were not broken
and again quote I've been repeatedly
assured that no rules were broken
now these quotes which are on screen are
also at Pages 64 to 65 of your evidence
bundle
may I ask did any government law officer
or any member of the government legal
department
such as the Attorney General solicitor
general or any one of the hundreds of
solicitors and barristers that work for
the government did anyone of those give
you the Assurance uh thank you very much
Mr Costa well I know they the short
answer is no they didn't but nor did I
seek assurances from uh from them nor
did I claim that I had I don't think I
claimed at any stage that I'd received
assurances from Law Offices or or legal
Representatives the people that I said
uh the the people who had given me the
assurances uh that there were uh there
were more than one and it was indeed on
more than one occasion and so if would
it be helpful if I if I if I told you
why I said I was repeatedly assured Mr
cluster asks his questions and then just
follow the course of his imagination if
you would very interested to heal of
course your full responses can I ask the
head of the Civil Service Simon key so
any other career senior permanent civil
servant give you these assurances
um well it follows from uh from I think
from Martin Reynolds evidence that he
thought that the rules had not been uh
broken
um if you if you look at what he has to
to say
um
I don't
I don't remember being specifically
assured by any senior civil servant
about the rules uh or the guidance
within uh within number 10 but the the
interesting thing is that
to the contrary nobody
gave me any country
if we may thank you in paragraph 90 of
your very helpful written submission you
say that the assurances were given to
you by Jack Doyle and James slack that's
right their statements confirming this
are on pages 70
72 and 75 of your evidence bundle yeah
now they are both individuals you had
personally appointed to the position of
director of communications at number 10.
they were political advisors who dealt
with the media
why did you rely on an assurance from
political advisors rather than as I've
mentioned a permanent civil servant
because or more importantly a government
lawyer so here's the here's the art the
the simple answer is that when I needed
to discover what had happened whether
the rules were broken I went first of
course or I've asked first the senior
advisor who was there and that was Jack
Doyle uh the the following week you can
see that uh Jack Doyle says that uh he
he
confirms that he he says in a WhatsApp
to me I've been you can say I've been
assured that there was no party and no
rules were broken so he says that again
uh to me I also then rang James slack
who and both Jack and uh and and James
slacker people have the utmost regard
for uh and I believe they would be
completely straight with me about what
and they both said that the rules had
not been broken and the the reason I
didn't ask a lawyer or another senior
civil service because they were the
people who'd been there
and they were the direct they they could
give a view about the legality of of
that event that uh I did I didn't think
a normal eyewitness would be able to do
okay well when you decided to rely on
the assurances that you've referred to
in the house why did you not then
discuss the Assurance with the cabinet
secretary Simon case or your principal
private secretary Martin Reynolds or a
government lawyer at the point at which
you've been given the Assurance by the
individuals that you've questions so
double check it with a government lawyer
first of all uh well Martin Reynolds in
addition to being my private private
secretary is a lawyer and his view of of
all the events as you'll see from his
evidence is that uh he believes that we
followed the uh the rules at all times
and that was certainly what he he said
to me uh you you'll see evidence uh Mr
Costa from the uh from the from uh from
my submission that uh at least a couple
of of MP colleagues remember from the
morning meeting that I asked generally
uh did we follow the rules were there
parties and the the view of the
assembled civil servants and uh uh
advisors was that no we uh no we hadn't
broken the rules and at the end and
that's what they said the MPS that
you're referring to are the ones at
paragraph 90 of your written submission
where you stayed that the evidence given
to us by Sarah dimes MP and Andrew
Griffith MP see seeing officials give
your assurances at your daily office
meetings those are the additional
assurances that you're referring to yes
and it's not clear what uh date that
um
uh Sarah and Andrew uh remember but they
certainly remember me receiving those
assurances and don't forget if I could
just make an important point from the uh
from the seventh to to the from the 7th
of December onwards uh the uh inquiry is
underway so you ask why I didn't ask uh
Simon case I did ask Simon case I asked
Simon case to conduct an inquiry well
I'm very grateful that you'd recall
Cedar Dam's MP and Andrew Griffith MP
giving you the assurances but you were
present at those meetings were those two
MPS said that Assurance hasn't been
given so if I just me ask the question
and you can correct me if I've
misunderstood the point who were the
officials who gave these assurances in
this meetings that you've referred to at
paragraph 90 in your written submissions
well I I can't name anyone I I don't
know if I I don't know if I can I think
that why not I think that most of them
have indicated they don't want
themselves
Mr Johnson could you just pause and
answer my question are you not naming
these officials who you say
we're giving you these assurances
because you can't remember who they were
or you can't remember their names or
because you don't want to do at least
because of confidential there's at least
one advisor that I can think of that uh
who was asked not to be not to be named
and she would be she would have been in
the morning uh meeting and
um I don't want to well could you follow
that up in writing through your lawyers
to the inquiry confirming the name of
the individual the Utica gave you the
assurance that the meetings referred to
by these but if I may say so Mr Foster I
don't quite follow the direction of your
of your questions because it's clear
from what I've said that I was assured
on uh I was assured repeatedly by uh
different people and on different
occasions that the rules have been
followed well and we've tried to
ascertain who these individuals were so
be very helpful if you could follow up
with the individual who's just referred
to now could I ask the team to place
slide 9 in on the screens please
now slide nine refers to a comment made
by Mr Doyle and that will also be found
at page 74 of the bundle
Mr Doyle is asked the question was there
a discussion in this meeting the meeting
of the 8th of December 2021 whether
coveted guidance was adhered to at all
times
and Mr Doyle States
quote I did not advise the prime
ministers to say this no
so Mr Doyle says he did not discuss with
you whether any Gatherings had been
compliant with covert guidance
is it correct that you received no
assurances that the Gathering of 18th
December 2020 or any other Gatherings
were compliant with covid guidance yes
it's uh it's correct to say that uh I
did not as far as I can remember that I
didn't receive direct assurances about
the uh December the 18th event about the
the guidance
um but until Martin Reynolds made his
point to me on the morning of the eighth
uh nobody had said to me anything
adverse about our following of the
guidance and it was my impression from
what we were doing from my lived
experience in number 10 that we worked
in about assurances
so let me carry on if I mean Mr Mr
Johnson can I ask you to turn to Pages
70 and 73 of your evidence bundle and
you'll see excerpts from Mr Doyle's
signed witness submission
now Mr Doyle says
and I quote
the lines that were drafted for the
mirror that's the Daily Mirror
it became the basis of Mr Johnson's
lines to take in prime minister's
questions on the 1st of December 2021
end quote
he also says in relation to a
conversation he had with you on the 30th
of November quote I said that we have
had an inquiry from The Daily Mirror
he said what is our line
end quote page 76 of your evidence
bundle shows the line sent to the mirror
was quote
rules were followed at all times
end quote
so that line Mr Johnson the assurance
that you relied on in the House of
Commons on the 8th of December was
initially developed as no more than a
media line to hold a Bay Press inquiries
wasn't it yes but I don't see any great
advice in that and I think we have to be
absolutely realistic about how
government is carried on and if a
minister cannot rely on the uh advice of
senior entrusted officials when you have
to get a huge amount of business done
okay then it would be impossible for
government to carry on could I ask you
um uh you've acknowledged that it was
oh I think we need to hear from Mr Costa
his next question thank you thank you
chair it is the case isn't it that Jack
Doyle the person who's purported
Assurance you sought to rely on was
himself doubtful about the compliance of
some of these gatherings with the rules
and guidance
now Mr Johnson sorry I don't know where
where where when do you drive there
if you turn to page 79 of your evidence
bundle
saying he said if it's time to page 79
of your evidence bundle you will see a
selection of WhatsApp messages sent by
Mr Doyle
these messages are discussing the
Gathering of the 19th of June 2020 that
marks your birthday
Mr Doyle says that he was and I quote
struggling to come up with a way
that the Gathering was in the rules and
that he was quote not sure it would
quote work
to suggest it was reasonably necessary
for work purposes
were you we are Mr Johnson that your
Trusted Senior advisor as you've put it
Mr Doyle doubted whether this Gathering
was within the rules so uh no is the
answer to that question I wasn't aware
that he'd said that WhatsApp he didn't
send it to me this was I think on
January the 25th uh which is
um long after we've started the the
process which was to become the Sue
great I think the Sue gray inquiry was
already well underway a couple of other
quick points if I may uh on uh that that
WhatsApp
um
Jack was not at that event on the 19th
of June uh 2020. uh he knew nothing
about what had actually taken place he
was then relying on media descriptions
of that event uh which had subsequently
emerged and yes uh he sent her a message
to someone else uh saying he needed to
work out uh what the the justification
was but
just to go back to the to the June the
19th event 2020 which we've been over
several times at the time I thought it
was so innocent uh that uh it was it was
actually briefed out to to the time I'm
talking about assurances you were given
so let me Focus again so how can it be
that Mr Doyle and this is the the point
I think is important for the inquiry to
understand how can it be the Mr Doyle
one of your principal advisors your
trusted advisor the person whose
Assurance utilized on in the House of
Commons was himself clearly doubtful
about the compliance of this gathering
with the rules but you continue to see
that you were not how can that people if
he wasn't at that event uh he was
struggling to contend with media
accounts of it long after that event and
after the uh the Sue gray inquiry had
already begun and above all he did not
even at that time let alone before I
stood up in the House of Commons raised
with me any concerns that he might have
had about that event thank you even if
he knew about it I'm almost finished Mr
Johnson why did you tell the House of
Commons that you had received repeated
assurances that no rules had been broken
when you knew that that was not the case
because you knew what the rules were you
were at Gatherings that reached Turtles
and the preachers of the rules would
have been obvious to you at the time
that's that's not the case
yeah
I might see your Reliance on the
purported assurances you received as and
forgive me as a deflection mechanism to
prevent having to answer questions about
your knowledge of these gatherings would
that not be a fair assessment no it
would be completely ridiculous
assessment I said in the uh in the in
the Commons on the uh on the 8th of uh
December that I've been repeatedly
assured uh that there was no party and
that no rules were broken I was
referring to the December the the 20th
sorry 18th event December the 18th event
of the previous
year of 2020
um
I had the assurances that I had received
about that event uh were from people
that I had the utmost respect for and
who were directly relevant to my
understanding of what that event
consisted of it was entirely sensible to
talk both to Jack and then jackdoll and
then to James slack to find out to get
their honest take about what had
happened and my
impression
on the 30th of November 2020 from what
Jack was telling me was that it sounded
like
it was in accordance with the rules it
sounded like it was necessary for for
work purposes but also it sounded from
what he was saying that it was in
accordance with the guidance when that
turned out following the Allegra video
uh to be in question I commissioned
Simon case the cabinet secretary to
conduct an inquiry so by the time I uh
so and if you look at that statement I
say I've I've been repeatedly assured
that there was no partying that the uh
the rules were followed but I have asked
Simon case to investigate so for the
purposes of the house
my my statement uh it should be seen in
the for the purposes of the business of
the house that statement should be seen
in the context of the investigation the
inquiry that I have just launched in
which in the same pmqs I say I'm going
to uh make sure that the findings are
placed in the library of the House of
Commons
very much indeed for answering my
questions thank you Mr Johnson did I
just uh put a point to you because
because I along with my colleagues was
in the house at the time when these
assurances were given and we took them
to be serious assurances you've told the
house you've received assurances would
you not expect us to be a bit dismayed
to hear that it was not from the senior
civil servants it was from political
appointees that they themselves had
doubts about it they don't only canvas
it only covered one Gathering it didn't
cover the other three and it only
covered the rules it didn't cover the
guidance I think if you'd have said that
to us in the house and also you were
there at the time so it's a bit hard to
understand sorry could you let me finish
my point you were there at the time so
it's a bit hard to understand what the
nature of an assurance is when you have
been there and seen it with your own
eyes I mean if if I was going at 100
miles an hour and I saw the speedometer
saying 100 miles an hour it would be a
bit odd wouldn't it if I said somebody
assured me that I wasn't because it's
what you've seen with your own eyes you
actually think that we're a bit
entitled to be a bit
at face value that these assurances
amounted to something and it looks from
what you've told us in answer to Mr
coss's questions that they did not
amount to much at all so first first of
all I think a great expect chair uh if
you're talking about the December the
18th 2020 event I don't know there's
some confusion I was not there uh that's
one of the three I was not there
and if you look at the statement that I
made in the House of Commons and because
this was the relevant issue because the
Allegra video related to the December
the 18th event the the leader of the
opposition's questions the previous week
related to the December the 18th event I
was answering about the December the
18th event because that was the the
matter in question I had received
as I said
repeated assurances by different people
that are different more than one
occasion and more than one person that
the event was uh in accordance with the
rules
and I had that both from uh as I said
Jack Doyle and James slack now the the
question that I I think the committee is
trying to to to
unpick is is that a good enough
Assurance is it good enough to rely on
the director of communications and the
former director of communications about
one event no matter how eminent they may
be
and I think the answer is yes himself
had doubts I think
no sorry forgive me uh he offered that
that's not correct uh Chad uh the
director of communications Jack Doyle
did not say at the time that he briefed
me about the December the 18th event
that he had doubts about whether the
guidance was smaller did have doubts can
I just sorry sorry
where's your evidence for that
in relation to one Gathering not the
others it only gave assurances of the
rules not about covid sure I was being
asked about the one Gathering the leader
of the opposition you you played his
clip just now
that was everybody saw it he was asking
about he said what was there a party in
which loads of people came uh a
Christmas party in dining Street last
year that was the question that was then
uh when I said that the guidance was
followed completely at all times that
was then called into question by what
Allegra uh Stratton had to say uh so we
immediately instituted the uh inquiry by
by Simon case but that remained the
point at issue the pointed issue was
what had happened on December the 18th
and really if the if the if the
committee is going to say that I can't
rely uh on the advice of senior people
uh like uh Jack Dolan and James slack
who had the advantage of actually being
there then it's really going to make it
very difficult for government to be
carried on
um Mr Johnson just two points arising
from
when you're ready
two points arising from uh the recent
questions and answers first of all on
the question of uh Sarah dines
um a statement of evidence where she
mentions that either on the 1st of
December or the 8th of December
uh she recalls are you asking we did
follow the rules at all times didn't we
and this is in your paragraph 90 of your
submission and I recall more than one
person in the room said yes of course
and she says I'm not certain who the
people were but I am and I quote I'm 90
sure one of them was Simon case the
cabinet secretary
um and um uh the difficulty we have with
that evidence is in the sworn statement
from Simon case which I'm afraid is not
in the call bundle but it's on page 33
oh it's uh on uh 791 and 792 of the
general bundle and um don't waste time
fumbling for it because I will explain
he's asked about both these meetings
um and he makes it clear that there was
no dis was there discussion in the
meeting of the following points and if
so what would the blue cells of that
discussion uh he says I do not believe
any of these topics were discussed at
the meeting and he's asked a general
question on 793 are you aware of any
other meeting where Mr Johnson was
present where the points listed in Parts
E and F were discussed and that's
whether there was any discussion about
compliance with the guidance of the
years and he says no
so we have a difficulty giving any
credibility to the evidence we've
received from Sarah dines albeit I'm
sure she gave that evidence in good
faith
then there's the question of your
Reliance on I mean if you've got
anything to say about that I should give
you the opportunity well I I think if
you're going to question her evidence
then then you you need to hear it from
from her
I can't comment on her I can't comment
on her I can't comment on what Simon
cater said well like what I what I what
I what I do remember uh are uh General
affirmation uh from uh from colleagues
that uh it was the line I was about to
use in pmqs that uh the about the rules
uh being followed was supported do you
remember Simon case
saying frankly frankly I I I I I I I I I
I'm not questionable but you should ask
him I'm not questioning the veracity
because you were there I'm not
questioning the veracity of her
statement as she believes it because she
is quite open she says she's only in 90
not sure she's not sure sorry I wasn't
relying for for what I said on on the
camera I think it's terribly important
that we interrogate Sarah Downes we will
because no I don't think I don't I think
it's probably totally irrelevant I think
that the key point is that when I said
that I'd had repeated assurances uh I
was not okay I never claimed that I had
one of those people giving me those
assurances was Simon case okay but
there's another more General point you
say I see no great Vice in that that is
relying on the Assurance of Mr Doyle who
was a unappointed political advisor not
a professional civil servant uh uh not
an Empire thanks regret
um well we're not relying on Sue Gray's
elephants right in this particular
inquiry
um
the obligation not to mislead Parliament
is a very serious obligation on any
Member of Parliament let alone a
minister and it requires the MP or the
minister to take due care doesn't it yes
yes so if I'm I have to say if I was
accused of law breaking
um and I had to give undertakings to the
House of Commons of all places that I
had not broken the law I would want the
advice of a lawyer I would want the
advice of somebody really independent
and capable and you didn't answer the
cabinet drop you for 10 seconds yes I
wasn't accused of law breaking I was
asked to say uh what had gone on at a
party or an event
in the media room on the 18th of
December 2020. if I was asked to give
undertakings that rules and guidance had
been followed and and there was any
doubt about it there was the most
finished scintilla of doubt about it
well you'd want to copper plate your
assurances by showing that you've taken
proper advice absolutely put it to you
Mr Johnson you did not take proper
advice can I can I respond first by
saying that if you look at what I said
on uh December the 1st you have to it it
is true as Mr Carter said that I had
expected something like that question to
to come up but actually I thought that
the leader of the opposition would not
bother uh with that story uh okay
it is relevant the question is why did
you not take proper advice sorry sorry
sorry the the the the answer is quite
simply that over the and I've tried to
describe what I felt about these events
as they were happening nobody raised
with me uh or had any concern before I
stood up on on
December the 1st about those events you
did not I asked I did see this is
complete nonsense I mean complete
nonsense I asked the relevant people
they were Senior People they'd been
working very hard they gave me Jack
Doyle gave me a clear account of what
had happened
how was the cabinet secretary wasn't
that sorry you're wrong because I did
ask the cabinet secretary I did ask the
cabinet secretary to conduct an inquiry
on the 7th of December
what about whether you're undertaking
the House of Commons were correct
but of course that was what he was he
could move on
can we turn to Charles Walker
for our next questions
um
sorry that's
noise is coming from the back of the
room is
is that stopped okay uh Mr Johnson
housekeeping matters you're a
parliamentarian I'm a parliamentarian so
we do have a duty to Parliament
there's been a lot of noises off human
cry about the legitimacy of of this
inquiry which I do think we need to
address
you sort of alluded to it in your
opening statement I'll just give you an
example of
an organization that claims to have your
interests at heart it's called
conservative post
uh in a recent article published on its
website on the 12th of March
it's stated this was the headline
revealed the Privileges committee's
Great British stitch up of Boris
and the sentences so when labor proposed
referring Boris Johnson to the
Privileges committee for misleading
Parliament
many conservative MPS didn't oppose it I
just want to part that for a second and
take you back
about 11 months before that on the 21st
of April
when your case was referred to the
Privileges committee the government
Minister the right honorable Michael
Ellis QC the then Minister for the
cabinet office and pay Master General
said the following in Winding up
the government recognized the
seriousness of the issue under
consideration let me say at the outset
that the Prime Minister has always been
clear
that he is happy to face whatever
inquiries Parliament sees fit to hold he
is happy for the house
to decide how it wishes to proceed today
and and this is important because
because at the end of at the end of of
that the motion was put and there was no
vote
and that is a matter of of fact in
indeed there wasn't
even a cry of object from anyone can you
accept that was the case yes I I I
encourage people to to support it so so
it is actually misleading of
conservative posts to say many
conservative MPS didn't oppose it the
truth is not a single not a single
conservative MP opposed it yes that's a
completely correct that's great now this
is really good this is good we're making
progress
in your opening statement
you referred to the the chair uh the
appointment of the chair you suggest to
to some extent
um that you know you had concerns but
you you were willing to set those
concerns aside on the 14th of June 2022
the right honorable lady for camberwell
and Peckham
um there was a motion to add her to the
committee on the 14th of June 2022.
and um it went through at the end of a
debate on the privatization of Channel 4
and there were colleagues of ours in the
chamber and when the motion was put and
the right honorable lady's name was
mentioned there was not a single Cry of
object not one not even from a little
mouse scuttling across the floor not a
single Cry of object on the 14th of June
can you accept that as well uh of course
so if these concerns were live about the
committee and our legitimacy or the
legitimate of the chair somebody might
have shouted object
so Charles you kind of just come back
quickly on this on this point uh my my
anxiety is about uh the fairness uh are
contained in my uh submission uh that
I've said what I've had to say about the
previous remarks of the chair uh and and
I've said what I had to say about my
belief in the ability of this committee
which is very important to distinguished
committee uh to be impartial which were
made before her appointment on the 14th
and I uh have come before you this
afternoon uh in full confidence that you
will be impartial and that you will look
at the evidence and that you will
conclude uh that I did not wittingly or
recklessly mislead Parliament there's
not a shred of evidence to suggest that
I did and I hope that you will exonerate
me and I think you should exonerate me
of any contempt whatever so so look we
received your evidence bundle which was
really well put together it's been a
long afternoon we've shared the talking
you've had to do it on your own so so so
thank you for answering our questions
but it is a well put together bundle I
just feel that
the the way things have been conducted
is is is that your supporters I'm not
saying you I'm saying your supporters
seem to want it both ways they're hoping
that the evidence you've given in 52
pages will exonerate you given give you
a clean bill of health that's what your
desired outcome is but just in case that
doesn't happen there has been a
concerted effort to to delegitimize the
committee to call us a kangaroo court
have you characterized us as as a
kangaroo court you can tell by my
presence this afternoon by the uh
seriousness with which I've taken uh
your questions uh by my attempts to
answer in detail uh what you the points
you've you've put to me how seriously I
take you and your committee uh the
respect I have for this institution of
Parliament and
For Better or Worse whatever the the the
the issues of fairness that I I may have
raised in my submission this is the body
that decides on our standards and
privileges this is the committee that
does it there's no other way of doing it
that's why I have come here out of
respect for the committee out of respect
for Parliament and because I do not
believe that you can conceivably find me
guilty of wittingly misleading
Parliament on the basis of the evidence
that you have assembled so as as a
parliamentarian do you regret that
colleagues of ours who are also
parliamentarians have called the
Privileges Committee of Kangaroo Court I
I don't want uh anybody to calls any
colleague any uh uh there should be no
there should be no intimidation or uh
there should be no uh attempt to bully
any colleague in any matter whatever or
is that a yes or no yes but you regret
you regret that they sorry I I I'm not
because I regret it I'm not as a book so
my my questions of fairness are well
documented in uh my submission uh I
think that the the I I don't I deprecate
the term that you've just used I don't
want to uh repeat it but I think the
people will judge for themselves on the
basis of the evidence that you have
produced on the fairness of this
committee I have every confidence that
you will uh show that you can be fair
okay I'm I'm I'm I'm nearly I'm nearly
done can I just interject yeah
will you accept that this committee can
be fair and wrong rather than being
unfair in a Witch Hunt
um I I I certainly think that let me put
it this way Mr Costa I think if this
committee were to find me uh in contempt
of parliament uh having which would be
having come and done something so
utterly insane uh and contrary to uh my
my beliefs and my principles is to come
here to come to Parliament and wittingly
uh lie I think that would be not only
unfair I think it would be wrong but
indeed but you wouldn't categorize it as
a witch hunt or a kangaroo court that's
the point I I think he does
wait to see how you proceed with the
evidence uh that you have but I I I do
not I do not wish to uh
you know I I will study I will study
your conclusions uh from the evidence I
deprecate the terms that you have used I
don't want to see uh good colleagues
feeling that they're under pressure
either way I believe that uh if you
study this evidence impartially uh you
will come to the conclusion that that
I've that I've given nearly done
um on the 25th of May you describe
number 10 and here are the speech marks
a building that is 5 300 meters square
across five floors excluding the flats
hundreds of staff are entitled to work
there and I'm really sorry I think this
is probably the last time you're going
to be taken back to these dates on the
first of December you will be well aware
that you said to the leader of the
opposition all guidance was followed
completely in number ten on the 8th of
December against the leader of the
opposition you said I have been
repeatedly assured that the rules were
not broken and then I'll rattle through
this quickly on the 8th of December to
Catherine West
regarding 13th of November alleged party
I'm sure whatever happened the guidance
was followed and the rules were followed
at all times
I
you was you received assurances from a
number of people I suppose the question
I've got is how an earth
would they have no and the rules were
being were being followed all time it is
impossible because you you
'd have cameras in every room I mean
well no but I had their pairs of eyes so
you're right so I didn't have
omniscience about what was going on in
the building and I had to rely on what
people told me you're completely right
to Charles but uh what they had to say
was extremely valuable and they were
extremely reputable people and are
extremely reputable people and they gave
a description of that event and it and
to get back to the point that the chair
was Raising uh initially it was it was
one event that was under consideration
under discussion and
um
I took my my cue from them
so I wanted to say this because I you
worked incredibly hard I accept you
Works incredibly hard I accept your
officials worked incredibly hard I
accept that you were hospitalized
um we got the vaccines out you worked
incredibly hard I suppose what I'm left
with and I'm not sure if this helps or
hinders your case is is when you look at
126 fixed penalty notice notices handed
out to number 10 it is clear that Simon
case Martin Reynolds Jack Doyle Lee Kane
James slack all of them really had no
idea what was going on because if they
had it is highly unlikely 126 fixed
penalty notices would have been handed
out and can I kind of say Sir Charles
that you put your finger on the crucial
Point uh because uh if the the committee
thinks that I must have known or to get
back to the conversation we've had the
doctrine of obviousness uh if if it was
obvious to me then it would have been
obvious to those others senior and
distinguished people it really wasn't
and I was very shocked to get my own fpn
uh and I'm amazed frankly by the number
of other fpns I clearly what happened uh
you know if we we don't want to go over
it again we don't want to reinvest it
but I think what happened basically was
that on a few evenings
events did simply go on far too long and
I can't apologize for that enough but
we are where we are I don't want to try
try your patience because you have been
here a long time
if not deliberate if not deliberate
is it possible that
it was Reckless or slightly Reckless not
to have caveat your your statements to
the house with you know to the to the
best to the best of my knowledge or I
really do hope it was it was the
certainty of the statement so yeah is it
possible to accept that actually
um there was a degree of of of of of of
recklessness no I mean no one nobody
wants to be in a position where they're
misleading that nobody wants to to say
something into the hazard Commons that
is going to be turned out not to be true
especially something as readily
falsifiable as the guidance was followed
completely it was it was my belief that
was the case I I have apologized and I I
continue to apologize for uh for
inadvertently uh misleading that and and
and I hope the the committee understands
that but it was it was it was not
deliberate it was based on my genuine
understanding and and uh belief about
what we were doing what we had been
doing for a long time and I think that
you're you'll point just now was was was
was the one of the most important ones
in this whole business uh it it wasn't
obvious to me uh that
there were problems with some events and
it wasn't obvious to uh the other senior
people that you've described
thank you
hitting the record issue because there's
been a lot of discussion about you
having corrected the record and I just
want to explore one aspect of that and
put this to you what you said on the
25th of May
2022 you said I'm happy to set on the
record now that when I came to this
house and said in all sincerity that the
rules and guidance had been followed at
all times it was what I believed to be
true and you've said that to us this
afternoon you then go on to say it was
certainly the case that when I was
present at Gatherings to wish staff
farewell
so what you said to the house
by way of a purported correction
was that it was certainly the case
when you were present at Gatherings to
wish staff farewell that the guidance
had been followed at all times
do you want to reassert that or do you
want to correct the record and
acknowledge here
um that actually the guidance was not
followed at all times just so we're
clear because you can correct the record
to this committee
so what I want to say is first of all
that the rules were followed and that's
for my last period those events and
that's clear from the FPS certainly and
it was my it was my belief uh at the
time that I made those statements that
the guidance was followed and actually
uh chair it remains my belief for the
time the time I was there when I was
when I was looking at these events uh I
thought they were within the guidance
given what I knew about what we were
trying to do given what I knew about the
limitations we faced on maintaining
perfect social distance and so what's
your belief is now so what I said I
don't wish to descend from what I said
on May uh the 25th well May the 25th was
five months after this had first been
raised
um and you'd had time to consider all
the issues that were being raised and
even further time has elapsed till here
we are now and there's a lot of evidence
that's been produced and you've had the
opportunity to consider do you still
want to assert that it was certainly the
case when you were present at Gatherings
to wish staff farewell that the guidance
had been followed at all times do you
want to assist I do this committee I do
what I did what I what I want to make I
I do and because I see no reason to
withdraw what I said on on May the the
25th because at that stage uh on May the
25th I was in possession of and I think
the the committee in the possibly the
world was it was in possession of all
the
um
uh
material that we've looked at today
my view
remains that the guidance allowed for
social distancing not to be carried out
with uh rigid drill sergeant Precision
particularly in difficult circumstances
such as the ones in which we were
operating provided you had mitigations
and so that that was my that was my you
asking it remains you're sticking with
that point and you don't wish to take a
correct thank you for the record thank
you
um that concludes our questions
um are there any final points that you
haven't already mentioned not ones that
you have mentioned but ones which you
would like to mention which haven't come
up in our questions we'd like to give
you the opportunity
thank you thank you very much I've I
much enjoyed our discussion well I I I
think it's been a useful I genuinely
think it's been a useful discussion and
I hope it's clear to the committee uh
what was in my heart and my mind on
December the 1st and December the 8th of
um
2021 and May the 25th and numerous other
occasions okay thank you Mr Johnson
litty will consider the evidence you us
alongside the other evidence we've
reviewed in the course of our inquiries
we may take further written and oral
evidence before the end of our inquiry
and before we reach our final
conclusions if we deem that necessary
and we've already discussed the
possibility of that but for now that
concludes our session today order order
thank you